wir steigen jetzt erstmal ein in die
Debatte zum Einzelplan 09 Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz und ampult ist Andreas
Mattfeld wie wir eben schon gehört haben
Berichterstatter seiner Fraktion für in
diesem Einzelplan eine massive
Umsteuerung eine Umsteuerung ihres Etats
und des
klimatransformationsfonds Hilfe
Wirtschaftswachstum hinzu
wirtschaftsstabilität vornehmen leider
meine Damen und Herren muss ich
feststellen dass sie gerade in diesen
notwendigen Bereichen nur ganz ganz
wenig fast schon homöopathische
Veränderungen vorgenommen haben und
erscheint Herbeck für sie steht nur
Klimapolitik im Fokus und dabei habe ich
doch häufig den Eindruck auch wenn ich
sie anschaue dass sie nahezu körperlich
die massiven Wirtschaft und
Wohlstandsverlust in unserem Land spüren
sie nehmen diesen aber in Kauf weil ihre
vermutlich jahrzehntelang antrainierte
ideologisch grüne DNA auf Ablehnung von
Industrie auf Ablehnung von Handwerk und
vor auf Ablehnung von Hochtechnologie
ausgerechnet ist und damit Herr habecker
meine ich nicht nur den Weiterbetrieb
der dringend benötigten Kapazitäten der
Kernkraftwerke über den April hinaus sie
fördern und das sehen wir ganz deutlich
in diesem Haus lieber das Lastenfahrrad
anstelle der so wichtigen Arbeitsplätze
in der Hochtechnologie wie zum Beispiel
der maritimen Wirtschaft sie setzen die
Axt an bei der für den Export so
wichtigen Außenwirtschaft und sie
kürzende nachgeordneten Bereichen die
gerade für die Wirtschaft nahezu
vielfach schon als Dienstleister von
besonderer Bedeutung sind massiv sie
kürzen zugunsten ihrer grünen Ideologie
nahezu in allen Bereichen mit
Ausstrahlung auf Forschung mit
Ausstrahlung auf Bildung mit
Ausstrahlung auf Arbeitsplätze der
Zukunft und auf neue Branche und habe
ich kann sie nicht ersparen sie
gefährden somit den Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland und viele in den Medien die
geben in diesen Tagen ja das Wort raus
von der d-industrialisierung ins Landes
ich will gar nicht so weit wie im Liegen
das zuzutrauen aber ein bisschen Kern
liegt darin schon und dabei merken sie
doch schon wie verzweifelt die Menschen
wie verzweifelt vor allem auch die
Unternehmen in unserem Land sind
Fachkräftemangel Rohstoffmangel
Inflation Energiepreise abreißende
Lieferketten lassen doch unsere
Wirtschaft und lassen auch die Menschen
von Tag zu Tag nervöser werden sie
reagieren hierauf die reagieren hier
drauf nahezu immer zu spät und vor allen
Dingen reagieren sie falsch meine Damen
und Herren und das
mussten wir leider
leidvoll auch bei diesen
Haushaltsberatungen gerade im Bereich
der Energiepolitik mehrfach erleben Herr
Habeck es wäre klug gewesen dass sie
sich dem Paket der Union für
Wirtschaftswachstum und Fachkräfte
Sicherung nicht komplett verschlossen
hätten in all den Jahren zumindest
unserer Regierungszeit haben wir als
Union gerade für Ihr Haus dort wo auch
ihre grüne Fraktion die
fdp-anträge eingebracht hat diese immer
mal wieder gemeinsam auf dem Weg
gebracht gerade auch weil es mir ganz
persönlich wichtig war nach außen zu
dokumentieren dass Demokraten doch mehr
Gemeinsamkeiten als den Trennen des
haben
[Applaus]
dass sie diese
geübte Zusammenarbeit jetzt komplett
eingestellt haben das zeigt mir
zumindest dass sie ausschließlich auf
Trennung als den auf verbindendes
Aussehen wir
wir als Union wir sehen das anders und
deshalb haben wir
zahlreiche Anträge die wir von ihrer
Seite für nachvollziehbar gehalten haben
zugestimmt sie hingegen haben alle aber
wirklich alle unsere Anträge zu
abgebügelt so wollten sie keine 195
Millionen Euro für handwerkliche Berufe
in unterschiedlichen Programmen frei
machen damit wollten wir gerade den
jungen Menschen im Handwerk doch
signalisieren welch ein besonderen
Stellenwert ihre Ausbildung für unser
Land hat von der Ampel abgelehnt nicht
mal die Nachnutzung der ausgeförderten
gastfeldern durch Geothermie wollten sie
mitmachen oder unseren Antrag zu den
erforderlichen 1,4 Milliarden Euro für
die Raumfahrt Industrie damit wir
bereits in diesem Haushalt unsere
nationalen und internationalen
Verpflichtungen klar abhängen wir
wollten und wollen diese
Hochtechnologien an deutschen Standorten
und ich darf das auch sagen wir hatten
jetzt die ministerratskonferenz wir
wollen die Atem des Mondes Mission und
gemeinsam mit dem Amerikaner deutsche
Astronauten auf dem Mond zu entsenden
denn gerade die artemis-mission meine
Damen und Herren die ist wichtig um auch
junge Menschen für zukunftsweisende
hightech-berufe zu begeistern den eines
Herr Habeck ich glaube da müssen wir
häufiger mal drüber reden das dürfte
aber klar sein nur mit gender Studenten
nur mit denen ihnen sehr nahestehenden
klimaaktivisten da bauen Sie in unserem
Land nicht eine Wärmepumpe ein
und an einer Stelle Herr Habeck und das
möchte ich ausdrücklich an ihre möchte
ich ausdrücklich an ihre Stelle auch an
Frau Dr Christmann sagen da erkenne ich
es ausdrücklich an dass wir bei der
Vorbereitung der ESA
ministerratskonferenz zur Raumfahrt
intensiv gesprochen haben und dass wir
diese Konferenz gemeinsam vorbereitet
haben es war immer gute Tradition dass
wir zumindest bei internationalen
Aktivitäten über fraktionell handeln und
deshalb danke dass Sie die von uns in
den Blickpunkt in der Vergangenheit
gerückten Projekte jetzt fortführen dass
Sie auch unsere Vorschläge wie Exo Mars
die Ariane Rakete mit einem
selbständigen europäischen Zugang zum
all und die artemismission dann doch
noch mitgetragen und dass sie diese
gezeichnet haben
dennoch abschließend zum Schluss mein
Rat Herr Kollege Harbeck nehmen Sie den
Bereich Wirtschaft im Namen ihres
Ministeriums ernster Dennis gerade die
Menschen in Industrieproduktion und
Handwerk die den Karren in unserem Land
ziehen diese Menschen wollen auch in
Zukunft in ihren Unternehmen anständig
Geld verdienen und nicht durch eine
realitätsferne Politik ihren Job
verlieren herzlichen Dank
Andreas Mattfeld war das in der Debatte
über den Einzelplan 09 Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz der hier jetzt diskutiert
wird und in dieser Debatte spricht jetzt
die italienische Check der
wirtschaftspolitische Sprecher der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin unser
Berichterstatter Felix bannaschak kann
heute auf eines Grund eines sehr
erfreulichen persönlichen Umstandes
nicht an der Debatte teilnehmende
deswegen nicht das heute in die Hand
auch zu danken den hauselter:innen für
die umfangreiche Arbeit der letzten
Wochen und Monate diesen
Regierungsentwurf zu verbessern und 790
Millionen Euro umzuschichten übrigens
Herr Mattfeld in Richtung der Zukunft
Investitionen und einen Vorschlag der
von ihnen kam war ja zum Beispiel den
internationalen Klimaschutz zu streichen
das ist natürlich kein Beitrag für
Zukunftsfähigkeit ganz im Gegenteil
wir haben die Bereiche Klima und Energie
mit 420 Millionen Euro zielführend
gestärkt und ausgebaut auch beim Bereich
der Digitalisierung mit 370 Millionen
Euro Innovationen und Stärkung zu
Resilienz ausgegeben wir zeigen mit
diesem Haushalt in der Krise wollen wir
in die Zukunft investieren Innovation
ist jetzt das Leitbild was wir brauchen
den du so kommen wir entschlossen aus
der Krise mit erneuerbaren Energien
Energieeffizienz entschlossener
Digitalisierung und das trägt diesem
Haushalt Rechnung
ich warne auch da vorher Mattfeld und
das erlebe ich in den letzten Wochen
sehr intensiv dass die Union unseren
Standort schlecht redet wir haben ein
schweres Jahr aufgrund des russischen
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine aber wir
haben auch gemeinsam hier im Parlament
vieles auf dem Weg gebracht ich erinnere
jetzt an die Beratung akutes zur Gas und
strompreisbremse die Gasspeicher sind
voll die Preise gehen nach unten wir
haben Investitionssicherheit geschaffen
in den letzten Wochen und Monaten daran
müssen wir festhalten und sollten nicht
den Standort schlecht reden in einer
solchen Phase
wir haben uns auch
Zukunftsthemen angenommen ich sehe
unsere Koordinatorin für Luft und
Raumfahrt einer Christmann vielen Dank
dass die Bundesregierung auch vier
Milliarden Euro jetzt auf der ESA
ministerratskonferenz eingebracht hat
dass wir hier diesen wichtigen Bereich
auch entschlossen stärken
auch das Thema noch zu erweitern auch
für die Grace klimasatelliten haben wir
134 Millionen für die anschlussmissionen
auf den Weg gebracht ist auch ein
wichtiger Meilenstein für die
Klimaforschung also sie sehen wir
kümmern uns intensiv um die Bereiche die
uns aus der Krise rausführen
Krisenbewältigung ist dieses Jahr aber
es geht jetzt entschlossen darum
Sicherheit Zuversicht zu schaffen fürs
kommende Jahr daran arbeiten wir sehr
intensiv
ein Thema was uns sehr umtreibt ist das
Thema wirtschaftliche Souveränität wir
geben über 879 Millionen Euro für die
Mikroelektronik aus im Rahmen der
websiteprogramme das heißt wir wollen
den Standort Deutschland Europa das
betone ich ganz besonders wir müssen die
europäisch denken stärken das heißt
europäische Souveränität ist deutsches
Interesse und auch das bildet sich in
diesem Haushalt ab
der Einzelplan 09 hat ja den Mittelstand
als ein besonderen Fokus gerade kleine
und mittlere Unternehmen sind uns ein
besonderes Anliegen hier die
industrielle Gemeinschaftsforschung
haben wir mit 20 Millionen Euro gestärkt
und natürlich ist es essentiell dass wir
jetzt auch den Mittelstand bei der
Transformation Stärken deswegen freue
ich mich sehr dass es auch gelungen ist
ein Transformationsprogramm für klein
und kleinsten Unternehmen im Wert von
100 Millionen Euro auf den Weg zu
bringen zu können zum Beispiel dann
Bäckereien Metzgereien ihre
Transportprozess Energie umstellen dass
es sehr wichtig für unsere Zukunft
es ist ein schwieriges Jahr für uns alle
ich glaube mancher freut sich wenn das
Jahr vielleicht auch vorübergeht aber
wir wissen das nächste wird nicht
unbedingt leicht
ich will trotzdem auch Danke sagen bei
all den Streitigkeiten die wir hier im
Parlament hatten haben wir auch vieles
gemeinsam bewerkstelligt und das ist
glaube ich auch wichtig dass wir
gemeinsam den Weg nach vorne suchen der
russische Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine
er ist nicht überwunden die Menschen
dort leiden wir investieren hier wir
schaffen Sicherheit auch soziale
Sicherheit wir werden das Thema
Fachkräfte in den Fokus nehmen in den
kommenden Wochen und Monaten auch das
ist sehr wichtig dass wir hier
Vorankommen aber es bleibt essentiell
dass wir in europäischer Gemeinsamkeit
investieren dass wir Sicherheit schaffen
und das legen wir mit diesem Haushalt
mit diesem Einzelplan 09 vor ich danke
Dieter Janecek war das der
wirtschaftspolitische Sprecher der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen nächster
Redner hier wird Wolfgang wiele sein aus
der afd-fraktion und das gibt mir die
Gelegenheit schnell noch mal was zu
sagen zu der Einlassung von Stefan
Brandner vorhin in der geodätatte der
hat er ja dagegen sich ausgesprochen
dass das bürgergeldgesetz hier noch mal
diskutiert und vor allem auch abgestimmt
wird
weil er gesagt hat die haushaltswoche
habe doch da unbedingt ein voran da
müssen wir mal erinnern an gestern
Nachmittag da hat der Bundestag nämlich
beispielsweise über das Energie
sicherungsgesetz abgestimmt über die
energiepreispauschale für Studierende
und über die Lkw-Maut also entweder
abgestimmt oder den Gesetzentwurf
eingebracht da gab es übrigens keinerlei
Einwände seitens der afd-fraktion das
wollte ich zur gesamte Wahrheit und zum
Gesamtbild noch beitragen und jetzt
haben viele zu tun
und dass Deutschland sich besonders
reinhängen müsse damit die restlichen 98
Prozent der Welt folgen das verbreiteten
sie Herr Minister Habeck kürzlich auf
Instagram
diese Geschichten sind eine gefährliche
Mischung aus Selbstüberschätzung und
Selbstbetrug
die ideologische Energiewende hat uns
vom Gas in gefährlicher Weise abhängig
gemacht denn mit Wind und Sonne alleine
kann man einen Industrieland nicht
betreiben
die Sanktionen gegen Russland dienen
ganz sicher nicht deutschen Interessen
und sie wurden ohne gründliches
Nachdenken losgetreten
andere Länder für Ungarn Tschechien und
die Slowakei schützen ihre Wirtschaft
und ihre Bürger viel besser als diese
deutsche ampelregierung
die Energiepreise jagen nun von Rekord
zur Rekord ein paar Jahrzehnte nach dem
Wirtschaftswunder steht Deutschland nun
vor dem wirtschaftsabgrund und der die
Industrialisierung täglich schreiben
Wirtschaftslenker brandbriefe nach
Berlin
viele Unternehmen stellen die Produktion
ein der Bäcker nebenan ist dann
natürlich bald pleite große Unternehmen
wie BASF verlassen Deutschland für viele
Bürger heißt das heute müssen sie zu
Hause frieren morgen ist auch die Arbeit
weg
mit preisbremsen immer neuen Milliarden
Paketen für Juniper Seefeld the und so
weiter legt die Regierung dem Patienten
Deutschland eine Infusionsnadel nach der
anderen
alle diese Infusion bringen aber keine
Heilung wenn das Ausbluten der deutschen
Volkswirtschaft nicht gestoppt wird
Wumms macht das sonst nur in der
Staatskasse und bald danach beim
Steuerzahler
wenn sie nicht als
abwirtschaftungsminister in die
Geschichte eingehen wollen habe ich dann
beheben Sie jetzt die wirklichen
Ursachen dieser Krise
legen sie ihre Ideologie auf die Seite
beenden Sie Energiewende und
wirtschaftsaktion
lassen Sie die Kernkraftwerke länger
laufen nicht nur ein paar Monate sondern
für Jahre
folgen Sie der Forderung aus der
Wirtschaft und lassen sie in nordstream
2 wieder in Betrieb nehmen dem Vernehmen
nach funktioniert eine höhere ja noch
lösen Sie den sogenannten Klima- und
transformationsfonds auf der nichts
anderes ist als ein Schattenhaushalt ein
intransparenter Geldspeicher für ihre
Ideologie Projekte
die Zeit des Geschichtenerzählens ist
vorbei Deutschland steht am Scheideweg
wer glaubt dass kleine Deutschland
könnte für den ganzen Erdball
Lehrmeister dafür sein wie man das Klima
rettet
der wird der Ball ganzen Welt bald nur
eines zeigen nämlich wie man sich selbst
ruiniert
reißen sie das rote herum werfen sie
ihre Ideologie beiseite stoppen Sie das
Ausbluten unserer Volkswirtschaft dann
werden sie die AFD auf ihrer Seite haben
mit einer Politik für die Zukunft
Deutschlands aber sicher nicht mit den
Vorstellungen die sie uns hier als
Bundeshaushalt vorgelegt haben
der Bundestag diskutiert über den Etat
des Wirtschafts- und
klimaschutzministers der sich da gerade
auch ein bisschen amüsiert und da sie
sehr aufmerksame Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer sind ist Ihnen garantiert
aufgefallen wie häufig heute hier die
Farbe Orange vertreten ist in Blazern in
Pullover ein T-Shirts habe ich schon
gesehen Krawatten Einstecktücher alle
Varianten sind möglich auch die
Bundestagspräsidentin trägt eine
orangefarbenen Pullover das hat einen
Grund heute ist nämlich internationaler
Tag gegen die Gewalt gegen Frauen er ist
immer am 25 November und orange ist
symbolisiert die Zukunft ohne Gewalt
gegen Frauen also kein Zufall was sie
hier heute entdeckt haben sondern mit
System und durchdacht und mit einem
durchaus guten Grund Frank Junge ist am
Kult für die SPD-Fraktion
in diesen Zeiten meine Damen und Herren
multipla-krisen und existenzieller
zukunftsübergreifende Herausforderungen
kommt es auf einen Staat an der in der
Lage ist einen soliden einen sicheren
Haushalt aufzustellen damit es der
Wirtschaft Sicherheit und
Belastungsfähigkeit gibt aber auch den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern und genau das
meine Damen und Herren leisten wir mit
diesem Einzelplan und mit dem gesamten
Haushalt der Bundesregierung wir
entlasten die Bürgerinnen und Bürger in
dreistelliger Milliardenhöhe und ich
sage das noch mal ausdrücklich gerade
auch an die Union gerichtet die vom
Seitenrand immer gerne dicke Backen
macht und hier in einer nörglerischen
Art alles schlecht redet wir schaffen es
als Bundesregierung die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger in der Krise sie alle nicht
allein zu lassen und über
unterschiedliche Maßnahmen so weit zu
entlasten und durch die Krise zu führen
und das spürt auch die Wirtschaft wie
kann es sonst sein dass wir im dritten
Quartal diesen Jahres ein
Wirtschaftswachstum von 0,4% gehabt
haben
das ist wenig das zeigt aber dass wir
auf dem richtigen Kurs sind und die
Wirtschaft mit unseren Möglichkeiten
mitnehmen
meine Damen und Herren der Einzelplan 09
in Verbindung mit den Mitteln aus dem
Transformation und klimafond gibt uns
die Möglichkeit für Energiesicherheit
für unsere Bevölkerung die Wirtschaft zu
sorgen wir stellen uns der Aufgabe dem
Klimawandel weiter zu bekämpfen die
energiewärme und mobilitätswende
voranzubringen und die Transformation
der Wirtschaft ebenso das setzt voraus
oder zieht nach sich dass wir in
riesigen Größenordnungen in die in die
in die Infrastruktur
unseres Landes investieren und dass wir
vor allen Dingen dabei die
Transformation in Richtung Wasserstoff
als Energieträger der Zukunft ausbauen
beziehungsweise Elektromobilität fördern
und vor allen Dingen auch die Sanierung
der der Gebäude auf klimaeffiziente Art
voranbringen dafür geben wir insgesamt
etwa 35 Milliarden Euro aus Geld was
eben nicht nur dafür da ist
Wirtschaftskreisläufe in der Krise zu
stabilisieren Geld was uns dazu denkt
aus der Krise hinaus in die Zukunft zu
gehen und unseren Standort für die
Zukunft fit zu machen im übrigen und das
will ich auch noch mal sagen im übrigen
haben wir es in einer kurzen Zeit bis
Ende diesen Jahres geschafft die
LNG-Anlage in Wilhelmshaven ans Netz zu
bringen damit wiederum ein Faktor zu
installieren für Energiesicherheit zu
sorgen und Lubmin in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern wird Anfang des
kommenden Jahres folgen das zeigt wie
stark diese Regierung aufgestellt ist
und wie Sie genau die richtigen Weichen
stellt
meine Damen und Herren und das will ich
auch nochmal unterstreichen neben diesen
großen globalen Herausforderungen haben
wir den Schwerpunkt auf den kleinen und
mittelständischen Unternehmen das ist
das Rückgrat unserer Wirtschaft und vor
diesem Hintergrund nehmen wir das mit
Blick auf den Zusammenhalt in der
Gesellschaft sehr ernst vor allen Dingen
diesen Wirtschaftsbereich zu
unterstützen das Mittelstandsprogramm
Zinn will ich hier nennen und vor allen
Dingen auch die Industrieforschung für
Unternehmen das sind zwei Programme wo
wir vor allen Dingen kleinen Unternehmen
im strukturschwachen Raum und vor allen
Dingen auch im Osten sehr helfen können
ich will nennen dass wir unter dem
Aspekt des stärkens der Handwerker die
Ausbildung mit 70 Millionen Euro weiter
unterstützen dass wir denen helfen im
Rahmen von Bildungsinfrastruktur gut zu
investieren und ich will ja auch die GRW
nennen die GRW ist noch mal zu den 650
Millionen um weitere 175 Millionen
aufgestockt worden für die nächsten 10
Jahre um damit genau in dem Bereich
nordosthäfen aber auch die Raffinerie
stand im Osten zu unterstützen den
Transformationsprozess entsprechend zu
begleiten das sind genau die richtigen
Investitionen die wir jetzt in der Krise
brauchen und die an dieser Stelle auch
weiter für Sicherheit und für
Beschäftigung sorgen werden meine Damen
und Herren
ganz besonders froh bin ich an der
Stelle auf den Punkt das ist uns wieder
gelungen ist den Wiedereinstieg in das
europäische Programm im say health
vorzunehmen wir haben es dort geschafft
insgesamt in der Ampelkoalition
185 Millionen Euro bis 2028 in die Hand
zu nehmen um an diesem Programm
Synergieeffekte für unsere
Gesundheitsbranche nach sich zu ziehen
wenn es nämlich uns an der Stelle
gelingt Wertschöpfungsprozesse die aus
einem investierten Euro in mehrfacher
Form zu uns zurückkommen bei uns zu
verankern dann hilft das der Branche in
Größenordnung und auch das können wir
mit Blick auf den Wissenstransfer gut
gebrauchen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich komme zum Schluss ich will
zum Ende auch noch mal Dank an alle
Beteiligten Haushälter sagen aber auch
Herr Harbeck an ihre Mannschaft im
Ministerium wir haben intensive
Verhandlungen geführt und haben am Ende
einen Haushalt aufstellen können der uns
die Möglichkeit bietet nicht nur gut
durch diese Krise zu kommen
und vor allen Dingen auch die Weichen
für die Zukunft zu stellen und vor dem
Hintergrund darf ich Sie um Zustimmung
bitten
Frank Junge war das aus der SPD-Fraktion
berichterstatterie seiner Fraktion für
den Bereich Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz
und ungenau zu sein um für den
Einzelplan 09 ich schließ
e damit der Auszählung zu
das Ergebnis wird Ihnen später bekannt
gegeben
wir fahren weiter fort in der Debatte
und dieses später dürfte mutmaßlich in
zehn Jahren vielleicht 15 Minuten sein
denn das ist ja hier relativ schnell
ausgezählt da sind wir dann auch
natürlich noch dabei und können Sie dann
teilhaben lassen an diesem Ergebnis
Christian Laie ist am Pool der ist der
wirtschaftspolitische Sprecher der
Linksfraktion
dabei ist schlecht wie seit langem nicht
um es mit den Worten von Marcel
Fratzscher zu sagen die großen fahren
zum Teil auch in diesen Zeiten dicke
Gewinne ein während viele Mittelständler
die kleinen die Bäckerei um die Ecke
kaum mehr über die Runden kommen und ja
dies ist natürlich auch das Ergebnis des
wirtschaftskriegs mit Russland und wir
lernen Handelskonflikte Konflikte gehen
auf den Nacken der kleinen Leute und ich
sage das deswegen weil die USA Europa in
einen neuen Handelskonflikt drängen will
und diesmal mit China und bevor die
Blockbildung richtig an Fahrt aufnimmt
geht es doch darum die eigenen
Interessen mal zu sortieren und den USA
nicht blind links in den nächsten
Wirtschaftskrieg zu folgen meine Damen
und Herren
und neben den sozialen Kosten gibt es
dafür noch einen Grund und das sind die
Interessen der USA in der Krise haben
sie auf lng-gas aus den USA gesetzt dass
die aber zu Rekordpreisen verkauft haben
selbst Minister Habeck hat sich
gewundert das unter Freunden solche
Mondpreise aufgerufen werden und die
Folge davon ist dass bei solchen
Mondpreisen für Energie natürlich
Industrie Arbeitsplätze hier bedroht
sind und dann wird das
US-Handelsministerium auch noch gezielt
Industrieunternehmen ab und dann sollen
die gigantischen Summen des Inflation
reduction Acts nur fließen wenn die
Industrie auch wirklich in die USA
verlagert wurde und ich sage das mal
deutlich die USA werden aggressiv
zukunftsindustrie rund um die
erneuerbaren Energien ab und
gleichzeitig fordern sie Gefolgschaft in
einem weiteren Handelskonflikt mit China
dessen Rohstoffe wie aber genau für
diese Zukunft Industrien brauchen und
das bedeutet hier wird eine
reindustrialisierung der USA auf Kosten
einer Deindustrialisierung von Europa
Betrieben meine Damen und Herren tolle
Freunde sind das
und er habe ich
ich bin ja noch nicht so lange dabei
aber ich glaube zwischen Staaten ist das
manchmal wie bei Facebook das heißt nur
Freunde aber in Wahrheit geht es um
etwas anderes und bei Staaten da geht es
um Interessen und ich muss Ihnen sagen
in der globalen in der globalen
Blockbildung vertreten Sie unsere
Interessen bemerkenswert schlecht Herr
Minister so und wer ist uns und unsere
Interessen für Team blau sind das alle
mit dem blonden Haaren und für Team Geld
sind das Menschen mit viel Vermögen auf
der Bank aber wenn ich sage unsere
Interessen dann geht es um die
arbeitenden Menschen da draußen den
Mittelständler die kleinen die Bäckerei
um die Ecke und die werden gerade
schlecht vertreten in der laufenden
Blockbildung kommen diese Menschen unter
die Räder die Schlangen an den Tafeln
sind zu lang wie noch nie mehr als die
Hälfte der Bevölkerung spart inzwischen
beim Essen und deswegen braucht es eine
Wirtschaftspolitik die nicht aus falsch
verstandener Freundschaft in
Handelskonflikte rein stolpern sondern
die die Interessen der Menschen mit
kleinem un weiteren Einkommen
entschlossen und offensiv auch nach
außen vertritt dankeschön
nächster Redner für die FDP-Fraktion
Carsten klein
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Energiekrise stellt die Verbraucherinnen
und Verbraucher die Unternehmerinnen die
Unternehmer die kleinen die mittleren
die großen Unternehmen den Handwerk den
Handel die Industrie vor große
Herausforderungen und wir als
Ampelkoalition SPD Grüne und FDP Stellen
mit dem 200 Milliarden Programm des WSF
ein Programm zur Verfügung dass die
Energiepreise dämpfen wird und mit dem
WSF stellen wir uns an die Seite der
Menschen in diesem Land
und wieder Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse
2023 stellen wir uns an die Seite
zukünftiger Generation denn der WSF ist
ein konzentriertes Instrument das genau
auf die Herausforderung dieser Krise die
Energiepreise zu dämpfen abzielt bei der
gaspreisbremse bei der strompreisbremse
beim Härtefall vor und eben nicht das
Feld aufmacht für viele ausgabewünschen
wie wir es ja in der corona-krise bei
den Konjunkturprogrammen erlebt haben
nein ist ein konzentriertes Instrument
das dafür sorgt dass wir auch den Blick
nicht nur auf die Welt um dieser Krise
richten können sondern mit der
Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse auch auf
die Krisen zukünftiger Generation
und es gibt es in diesem Zusammenhang
noch drei wichtige Sachen zu sagen mit
dem WSF nämlich erstens damit es hier
keine Missverständnisse gibt diese
Misere auf dem Energiemarkt die hohen
Preise haben eine Ursache im
Angriffskrieg von Vladimir Putin in der
Ukraine die sind nicht von der
Bundesregierung initiiert und auch nicht
von einem Gas im Bad und das Deutschland
beschlossen hätte so wie es Friedrich
Merz noch im März vorgeschlagen hat und
das zweite was ich sagen möchte ist
jetzt kann man gegen all diese
Vorschläge sein die die Ampelkoalition
zu Recht auf den Weg gebracht hat Liebe
Union aber gleichzeitig keinen eigenen
Vorschlag einzubringen gleichzeitig
keine Haushaltsmittel einzustellen für
die Bekämpfung dieser hohen
Energiepreise das zeigt doch zweierlei
erstens sie lassen die Menschen sie
würden die Menschen in diesem Winter in
Kalten sitzen lassen und zweitens würden
sie dafür sorgen und der ihre
Regierungsführung das nächstes Jahr die
Industrie in diesem Land still steht und
deshalb ist es gut dass die Ampel
regiert und nicht die Union
aber eines möchte ich auch noch klar
adressieren auch im Sinne meiner
Fraktion zu den Verhandlungen die jetzt
in Brüssel stattfinden die Ergebnisse
die dort erzielt werden sollen müssen
selbstverständlich auf den Einigungen in
unserer Koalition auf diese
Vereinbarungen fundieren und deshalb
will ich nur noch mal darauf hinweisen
dass die Mittel für den WSF im Gegensatz
zu den Plänen der Regierung gesperrt
sind und der Haushaltsausschuss wird die
Mittel diese nötigen Mittel freigeben
wenn die Einigung wenn das was am Ende
beschlossen wird von der Bundesregierung
auf dem Fundament unserer drei
Fraktionen passiert und in keinem
anderen Fall liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und mit dem WSF machen wir eine aktive
Industriepolitik eine aktive
Wirtschaftspolitik im Gegensatz wie
gesagt zu den Ankündigungen der Union
aber Herr Minister sie machen ja auch
noch in einem anderen großen wichtigen
Bereich aktive Wirtschaftspolitik ich
möchte an der Christmann auch herzlich
Glückwünschen beglückwünschen zu dem
Ergebnis dass man den Verhandlungen bei
der esa-konferenz erzielt worden ist 4
Milliarden Euro die Bundesrepublik ist
nach wie vor der stärkste Zahler bei der
europäischen Raumfahrt wir haben uns
klar komm bitte zum Mondprogramm z.B
oder auch zu dem Joint aquemmend wenn
wir in Richtung Kleinsatelliten
resiliengekommen wie Kommunikation und
kleinsträger Raketen gehen das ist eine
richtige Weichenstellung dass dann da
noch mal ganz herzlichen Glückwunsch
wir werden diese Entscheidungen aber
auch flankieren wir haben diese
Entscheidung schon flankiert mit
Beschlüssen im Haushaltsausschuss wir
haben gemeinsam lieber Frank gemeinsam
mit Felix dem ich hier von auch noch mal
herzliche Glückwünsche ausrichten möchte
wir haben gemeinsam 31 Millionen Euro
nochmal für das nationale
Raumfahrtprogramm auf dem Weg gebracht
auch hier mit einem Baustein für
kleinstsatelliten für kleinsträger für
resiliente Kommunikation in einen
Wettbewerb der da ausgeschrieben werden
soll man sieht wir arbeiten sehr gut
miteinander wir kombinieren europäische
und deutsche Raumfahrt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen neben
einer aktiven Wirtschaftspolitik macht
natürlich das Wirtschaft und
klimaministerium oder muss das
Wirtschaft und Ministerium auch noch
eine koordinierte Klimapolitik machen da
haben sie Herr Minister leider nicht die
besten Voraussetzungen ihres Vorgängers
übernommen die Bundesrechnungshof
Berichte zu Energiewende sind
hinlänglich bekannt wenig Steuerung
wenig Koordination wenig Wirksamkeit
dass die Union jetzt im Zuge der
Klimakonferenz auch noch die
internationalen klimaschutzmittel
streichen wollte das soll ja auf jeden
Fall mal erwähnt werden finde ich
bemerkenswert aber ich glaube wichtig
ist dass wir auch Aufgaben haben wir
haben einen
energie-transformation vor mit 140
Milliarden Euro schönen Gruß an Fridays
for future ihre Forderung ist längst
erfüllt wir haben 4,2 Milliarden Euro
für den internationalen Klimaschutz das
Versprechen von Angela Merkel ist auch
erfüllt aber in Wahrheit wissen wir
nicht genau was mit diesen vielen
Instrumenten die im Haushalt haben am
Ende erzielt wird die Wirksamkeit muss
noch verbessert werden und deshalb ist
es gut dass wir jetzt Beschlüsse gefasst
haben dass das dass das Monitoring dass
die Berichte verbessert werden sowohl
beim Klima und Transformation vor wie
auch bei iki beim internationalen
Klimaschutz das ist uns gelungen und
deshalb werden wir in der nächsten Zeit
auch dafür sorgen dass es ein
koordinierten und wirksamen Klimaschutz
in Deutschland gibt vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit Karsten klein aus der
FDP-Fraktion in der Debatte über den
Einzelplan 09 Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz
gut dass sie noch dabei sind denn jetzt
kommt als nächstes Mal Jens Spahn aber
es kommt das Ergebnis zum
bürgergeldgesetz
Beschlussempfehlung des
Vermittlungsausschusses zu dem zwölften
Gesetz zur Änderung des zweiten Buches
Sozialgesetzbuch und anderer Gesetze
Einführung eines Bürgergeldes auf den
Drucksachen
3.873 4.226
4360 und 4.600 abgegebene Stimmkarten
657 mit ja haben gestimmt
557 mit Nein 98 Enthaltungen 2 damit ist
die Beschlussempfehlung angenommen
und zwar mit einer überdeutlichen
Mehrheit und da der Bundestag jetzt ja
gesagt hat zum bürgergeldgesetz kannten
sich auch der Bundesrat damit befassen
das wird dann in den nächsten Minuten
passieren wir werden Ihnen das
nachliefern sobald die haushaltswoche
des Bundestages zum Ende gekommen ist
und jetzt noch mal zu dem was ich eben
sagen wollte gut dass sie noch dabei
sind jetzt Jens Spahn stellvertretender
Vorsitzender der Unionsfraktion und
danach der zuständige Minister Robert
Habeck viele Menschen beginnen zu heizen
in ihren privaten Haushalten in den
Büros in den Unternehmen das Problem ist
nur viele müssen jetzt anfangen zu
heizen ohne wirklich zu wissen ob sie es
sich leisten können zum ersten ersten
das passiert gerade dieser Tage werden
viele Strom und Gaspreise erhöht die
Menschen erhalten die entsprechenden
Rechnung und die Wochen die Monate
vergehen es gab koalitionsausschüsse mit
entsprechenden Einigungen zumindest
scheinbar es gab die konzertierte Aktion
hat man auch schon lange nichts mehr von
gehört die Kommission hat mittlerweile
vor sechs sieben Wochen erste Vorschläge
vorgelegt es gibt jetzt einen ersten
Gesetzentwurf nach ersten Lesen muss man
sagen danach ist noch weniger klar als
vorher klar war es geht sie an sind sie
sind Wochen und monatelang sie sind
Wochen und Monate lang im Sommer gegen
die Wand angelaufen bei der gasumlage
haben Zeit vertrödelt jetzt hängt der
Winter an und die Menschen wissen immer
noch nicht was für sie gilt und das ist
ein Problem in diesen Zeiten
wir haben ja diese Woche sind wir ja
hier schon literarisch geworden aber
Stadt bei Louis Carrell hätte man besser
bei
Samuel Beckett nachgeschaut warten auf
Godo das ist es doch eher was hier
zutrifft wenn wenn Unruhe ist im Land
wenn es Montagsdemonstrationen gibt wenn
Menschen den Glauben an die Politik
verlieren dann hat das mit manchem zu
tun es hat aber vor allem mit einem zu
tun dass diese Bundesregierung auch so
viele Monate nach Kriegsbeginn auch
nachdem so viel Zeit hier eigentlich
vergangen ist so klar war dass dieser
Winter kommt und wo viele unsicher sind
bei den Gas und Strompreisen wenn jemand
Verantwortung hat für die Unruhe und
Unsicherheit im Land dann eine
Bundesregierung die nicht entscheidet wo
Entscheidung dringend notwendig werden
die wenigen Male wo sie konsequent
pragmatisch gewesen sind in den letzten
Monaten da waren sie erfolgreich und das
muss man auch anerkennen das war richtig
bei den lng-terminals die Beschleunigung
das war gut das war richtig sie ist
gelungen die gaspeicher zu füllen auch
das ist gut für den Winter aber da haben
sie eben alles beiseite gelassen was sie
bisher als Parteiprogramm Artikel hatten
was sie bisher gesagt haben haben
geschaut auf das was notwendig ist und
haben es getan aber damit aber damit
aber damit soll ich ihn zum Erbe von
Peter Altmaier kann ich Ihnen was sagen
ich war nämlich dabei ja ja warten Sie
mal ab es war der Finanzminister Olaf
Scholz der ja wie wir gemerkt haben
schon vergessen hat dass er reagiert hat
es war der Finanzminister Olaf Scholz
der den Bau von lng-terminal zum
US-amerikanisches Gast nach Deutschland
zu bringen davon abhängig gemacht hat
dass die USA die Sanktionen gegen Nord
Stream 2 aufheben es war Olaf Scholz wir
haben am Ende den Russen
entgegengekommen ist und in Amerikanern
nicht sicher Germanys bauen wollte das
war nämlich die Geschichte insofern
sollten Sie
öfter mal genau hinschauen was gewesen
ist da wo sie konsequent pragmatisch
waren waren sie erfolgreich da wo sie
nicht pragmatisch waren sehen wir
halbherzige Entscheidung nehmen Sie nur
die Kernenergie in der Debatte hier dazu
hat ein grüner Kollege gesagt es wäre
eine Zumutung diese Entscheidung treffen
zu müssen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die eigentliche Zumutung ist woanders
wir haben Bürgerinnen und Bürger die
sich den Strom nicht leisten können
jeder weiß es ist Angebots Knappheit
Preise gehen darunter wo das Angebot
breiter wird und auch verlässlich und
der nächste der übernächste Winter das
sagen auch alle Expertinnen und Experten
wird härter im Zweifel noch als dieser
und deswegen haben sie sich irgendwie
hingewürgt um 12 Wochen die Laufzeit
wohl zu verlängern wo zwei Jahre
notwendig gewesen sind die Zumutung die
waren nicht bei den Grünen die Zumutung
ist für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger eine
zu sehen wie sie sich zu den notwendigen
Entscheidungen
und deswegen scären auch so viel mehr zu
sagen will ich eines aber noch
grundsätzlich sagen zur Art der Debatte
weil wenn man das mal aufmerksam
verfolgt diese Woche dann stimme ich zu
ja in Zeiten wie diesen in Zeiten von
nationaler Krise brauchte es
Zusammenhalt und ja es geht auch um die
Art der Debatte aber um Einigkeit um
Einigkeit muss man sich auch bemühen und
wenn gelegentlich der Blick geworfen
wird auf die Krise vorher in der
Pandemie war Einigkeit in der
Bundesregierung über den Kurs da gab es
keine Debatte wir erleben hier das
Wirtschafts- und Finanzminister jeden
Tag miteinander streiten darüber was der
richtige Kurs ist in der Krise vorher
war Einigkeit mit den Ländern und den
Kommunen wir haben darüber herum
gerungen stundenlang um einig zu sein
mit Ländern und Kommunen sie haben es
geschafft unabhängig von der Farbenlehre
alle Länder gegen sich aufzubringen
innerhalb weniger Wochen auch das ist in
dieser Krise eine Entlastung um eben
Zusammenhalt herzustellen aber das
allerentscheiden ist die Frage des
Umgangs mit Kritik und wir haben das ja
gerade schon wieder erlebt in der
Debatte zum Bürgergeld Zusammenhalt
entsteht nicht durch das Beschwören der
eigenen Großartigkeit Geschlossenheit
entsteht nicht durch Gehorsam gemeinsam
nicht gemein sind nicht durch
gegenseitiges verächtlich machen
Zusammenhalt entsteht durch gute
Debatten um das Regeln durch um eine
richtige Lösung da wo sie da wo sie das
Gute Argument haben da wo sie das
bessere Argument haben sind wir ihnen
gefolgt aber Sie müssen es aushalten
denn es ist das Elexier einer Demokratie
und es ist die Voraussetzung für
Zusammenhalt das Gute Debatten auch
strittige Debatten geführt werden da wo
sie richtig liegen werden wir ihnen
zustimmen aber da muss ich falsch liegen
wo sie halbherzig agieren wo sie zögern
da wird es auch in Zukunft Kritik geben
gewöhnen sie sich daran
nächster Redner für die Bundesregierung
der Bundesminister dr Robert Habeck
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren bevor ich zum Haushalt komme
lassen Sie mich auf einige der reden
kurz noch eingehen ohne ist zu lang
machen zu wollen dennoch würde ich gerne
dass die Behauptung der AFD nicht
unkommentiert im Raum stehen bleiben sie
haben von deutschen Interessen
gesprochen und dass sie gewahrt werden
sollen ich sage Ihnen das wichtigste
deutsche Interesse ist dass
Kriegsfürsten nicht nach guteren Art
andere Länder überfallen dürfen dass
sich diese Politik in Europa nicht
durchsetzen und wo ich dabei bin
es ist nicht im deutschen Interesse das
im Stil von Russia Today hier Ursache
und Wirkung verdreht wird das ist nicht
im deutschen Interesse
dazu gehört auch
sie haben gesagt wir sollen die Ursachen
für diese Krise stoppen genau darum geht
es die Ursache für diese Krise zu
stoppen heißt Putin in den Arm zu fallen
und zu verhindern dass er sich
durchsetzt Sanktionen sind ein
notwendiges Mittel dazu genau das zu tun
und ich glaube auch dass der Weg
erfolgreich ist der Krieg in der Ukraine
ist sicherlich kein
Vorbild für andere Länder es ist ein
Desaster auf dem Schlachtfeld und es ist
ein Desaster für die russische Ökonomie
das nicht zu sehen heißt dass man
politisch blind ist sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren
damit würde ich zum Haushalt kommen und
kurz auf den Kollegen Mattfeld eingehen
lieber Andreas Mattfeld als ich ihn
zugehört habe habe ich mich schon
gefragt ob sie den Haushalt gelesen
haben es waren schon eine sehr
paralleluniversumslastige Rede die sie
hier gehalten haben sie haben gesagt wir
tun zu wenig für den Mittelstand das
Mittelstandsprogramm Zimmer ist auf 700
Millionen Euro aufgestockt worden sie
haben gesagt wir konzentrieren uns nur
auf Klima die haben übersehen dass wir
von der Gesundheitswirtschaft über die
Digitalisierung über die Cloud
Infrastruktur und über die Raumfahrt
große programmvolumina stemmen und die
deutsche Wirtschaft in allen Bereichen
für die Zukunft fit zu machen und zu
unterstützen
und wo ich dabei bin
Klima ist die Zukunft oder Klimaschutz
eine klimaneutrale CO2-arme
Produktionsweise und konsumweise ist die
ökonomische Zukunft es ist die
ökonomische Zukunft und wenn sie uns
schon nicht glauben möchte ich als
Beispiel den American in Flächen
reduction Act vor anführen der ja die
gesamte Feuerkraft der amerikanischen
Finanzmöglichkeiten auf
klimaanteiltechnologien konzentriert was
die machen ist exakt dass aus der
klimatransformation vor ebenfalls auch
macht nämlich die Förderung von
erneuerbaren Energien die Förderung von
Wasserstoff die Förderung von Batterien
die Förderung von Immobilität all das
ist der Inflation redakt die Amerikaner
haben sich also entschieden den
Leitmarkt den Kampf um den Leitmarkt
erneuerbare Leitmarkt zukünftige
Industrie zu führen allerdings ist damit
auch die Entscheidung getroffen wo der
leitenmarkt sein wird es wird ein
Wettbewerb zwischen den großen
ökonomischen Mächten geben wer am
stärksten am schnellsten am
entschiedensten diesen Leitmarkt einer
klimaneutralen einer grünen Industrie
aufbaut zu sagen das ist alles nur
ökokrams oder Klimaschutz verkennt die
ökonomische Auseinandersetzung in der
wir uns befinden die Zukunft wirkt
darüber entschieden wer am schnellsten
und am besten
Innovationskraft und Leistungsfähigkeit
in einem Bereich einer grünen Wirtschaft
aufbaut sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
wir haben ein rekordinflation wir haben
eine drohende Rezession wir haben
Energieknappheit wir haben Krieg in
Europa wir haben einen Wandel und das
ist die hüftliche Formulierung im
globalen Wettbewerb eigentlich muss man
sagen es ist eine immer stärkere
konfliktreichere Geopolitik die
zurückkommt wir haben die Klimakrise mit
enormen auch ökonomischen Folgen über
alle anderen will ich hier gar nicht
reden über das Elend der Menschen ich
habe als ich in Singapur war mit dem
Wirtschaftsminister aus Pakistan mich
getroffen
die wirtschaftsbeziehung zu Pakistan
sicherlich ausbaufähig aber was er
geschildert hat über das Sterben in
Pakistan wegen grassierender
Klimaveränderungen und es waren seine
Worte Klimaveränderung das hat einfach
mal ein ganz anderes Bild darauf gegeben
wir haben Rohstoffmangel sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren die Herausforderung für
denen dieses Land steht sie könnten
nicht größer sein
es bedarf einer enormen Kraftanstrengung
und diese Herausforderung zu stehen und
zu stemmen politisch wie
gesellschaftlich und der Haushalt des
Einzelplans 09 bildet diese
Kraftanstrengung ab die Gelder steigen
noch einmal der Haushalt umfasst
insgesamt 14,9 Milliarden Euro das sind
3,2 Milliarden mehr als der Haushalt 22
und wenn man sich anschaut worauf sich
diese Gelder konzentrieren dann sieht
man ziemlich genau die Strategie der
Bundesregierung kurzfristige Sicherung
in der Krise der eine Schwerpunkt das
sind die Investitionen in Betrieb und
Aufbau Schiffe Ersatz zu schaffen für
das russische Gas das ja schon nicht
gekommen ist ja es war Putin der das Gas
abgedreht hat so viel zu Nord Stream 2
sie haben offensichtlich zu viel Wasser
today geguckt sie müssen doch wohl
anerkennen sie müssen die Fakten
anerkennen dass das Gas aus Russland
nicht kam es gibt keine Sanktionen gegen
Gas zweitens Sicherung einer
Ölversorgung für Schwedt
pipeline-systeme aufzubauen als
Alternative zu der druckpipeline all das
spiegelt sich in dem Haushalt wieder und
kostet natürlich ziemlich viel Geld und
dann aber auch
dann aber auch die Konzentration auf die
Zukunftsaufgaben ich habe sie eben schon
erwähnt von der Cloud-Technologie zu
Unterstützung einer digitalen Wirtschaft
bisschen zu den
Investitionsprogrammen für den
Mittelstand im Bereich der Erneuerbaren
der eine Erneuerbaren Wirtschaft sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren der Einzelplan
60 ist der Einzelplan der das den
klimaansformationsformen beherbergt der
umfasst für das nächste Jahr 36
Milliarden Euro ich will damit sagen
dass die Summen die wir mobilisieren
durchaus erheblich sind und die Summen
sind mit den amerikanischen Ausgaben
durchaus wettbewerbsfähig die 400
Milliarden Euro die dort erstmal bereit
stehen wir haben über einen groben
Daumen geschätzt 200 Milliarden alleine
in Deutschland im Klima und
Transformation das ist durchaus
vergleichbar die Aufgabe ist dass wir
schneller und entschiedener werden
müssen bei Planung für Ausgaben und bei
dem Wettbewerbsrecht innerhalb von
Europa das heißt wir müssen
entschiedener und entschlossener werden
nicht zögerlicher und in Frage stellen
was wir eigentlich auch mit Verlaub in
diesem Haus schon erkannt haben denn den
klimaantransformationsfonds den haben
wir geerbt insofern das was eigentlich
am hinderlichsten ist bei einer
entschiedenen Wirtschaftspolitik ist der
permanente intellektuelle Rückfall auch
in die Jahre wo wir eigentlich schon mal
weiter waren sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren wir werden den Klima und
Transformation von nutzen um exakt
entlang dieser Strategie die nächsten
Schritte zu gehen wir sind gerade dabei
die Richtlinie für die sogenannten
karben-kontakt for differences zu Design
sie ist fertig sie befindet sich jetzt
in der Abstimmung mit den anderen Häuser
wir werden anderen Häusern wir werden
also im nächsten Jahr Verträge für die
Industrie anbieten die dann die
dekarbonisierung den Weg hin zu einer
Wasserstofftechnologie beschreiten wird
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
abschließend
wir sind mitten in einer Krise der Druck
auf die Wirtschaft und auf die
Bevölkerung ist enorm hoch wir kämpfen
uns aber und ich glaube das letzte Jahr
hat gezeigt dass wir das durchaus in der
Lage sind zu tun wir kämpfen uns aber
erfolgreich Schritt für Schritt aus
dieser Krise raus das nächste Jahr wird
nicht weniger hard werden der Haushalt
allerdings gibt uns die Möglichkeit
dafür die nächsten Schritte Zug Umzug zu
gehen und so diese Zeit zu überstehen um
danach in die richtigen Moment
reinzukommen und die Wertschöpfung die
Wirtschaft die Prosperität in
Deutschland hochzuhalten danke schön
der Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert
Habeck der ja bekanntermaßen auch für
Klimaschutz zuständig ist in der Debatte
über seinen Etat für das Jahr
2023 etwas 14 einhalb Milliarden Euro
hat er zur Verfügung um seine
politischen Ziele durchzusetzen live
ericon ist ja nächste Redner
stellvertretender Vorsitzender
afd-fraktion heute in einem Monat ist
Weihnachten dann soll der
Weihnachtsbraten auf dem Tisch stehen
aber viele werden in diesem Jahr wohl
darauf verzichten eine Weihnachtsgans
kostet mittlerweile an die 100 €. die
massive teurerung frisst sich immer
tiefer in unsere Portemonnaies über 10%
Inflation bei Lebensmitteln über 20%
Inflation und viele Produzenten haben
gerade erst ein Drittel der gestiegene
Produktionskosten an die Kunden
weitergegeben es kommt also wohl noch
dicker hier wird unseren Bürgern der
Wohlstand gestohlen mit dieser Inflation
und bedanken dürfen sich die Menschen
dafür bei Ihnen
auch bei Ihnen Herr Minister und bei
ihren Vorgängern die die dümmste
Energiepolitik der Welt betreiben wegen
der explodierenden Energiepreise
verlassen große Unternehmen unser Land
oder spielen zumindest jetzt schon mit
dem Gedanken eine Insolvenzwelle ist
bereits angerollt die reden jetzt
ernsthaft über die d-industriealisierung
unseres Landes das hätten wir uns doch
vor Wochen gar nicht vorstellen können
aber selbst in dieser dramatischen Krise
haben sie nicht den Mum zuzugeben was
offensichtlich ist ihre sogenannte
Energiewende ist krachend gescheitert
ich hatte vor einigen Wochen ein sehr
langes hörte zu ergriffen ein sehr
langes und ausführliches Gespräch mit
einem Unternehmen das sehr betroffen ist
mit Carla mit dem Porzellanhersteller
aus Thüringen der Geschäftsführer hat
mir die Zahlen seines Unternehmens
gezeigt und er wusste nicht wie es
weitergehen soll sein Gasversorger hat
ihm gekündigt weil auch der keine Ahnung
hat wie es weitergehen soll und jetzt
war das einzige Angebot dass er auf
Basis von Spot Marktpreisen ein Angebot
bekommen sollte was natürlich absolut
unmöglich ist weil ein Unternehmen
planen muss und stand gestern hat Carla
immer noch keinen passenden Gasvertrag
das ist die Lage in tausenden
Unternehmen in Deutschland und sie
ändern daran bisher überhaupt nicht
wann kommen sie endlich aus dem Knick
mit Gas strompreisbremse und wann
kümmern sie sich um die Ausweitung des
energieangebots sind das ist wirklich
Ursachenbekämpfung die wir brauchen wir
brauchen ausreichend Gas china
hat sich gestern in Mengen in rauen
Mengen Gas besorgt in Katar Herr
Minister sie waren da sie haben tief
gebuckelt vor den Scheiß es kam aber
nichts dabei heraus die Chinesen haben
sich langfristig gebunden und haben
ihren Vertrag gemacht wie die Italiener
schon zuvor sie bekommen es nicht auf
die Reise sie wollen es nicht auf die
Reihe bekommen das ist wirklich blanke
Dilettantismus in diesem
Wirtschaftsministerium
für uns bleibt dort nichts mehr übrig
aber wie wollen sie die Speicher füllen
im nächsten Jahr wie wollen sie es denn
machen
sie haben noch eine Chance sie haben
noch eine Chance wir brauchen den
funktionierenden Strang von nordstream 2
der ist notwendig wenn wir im nächsten
Jahr unsere Gasspeicher wieder füllen
wollen anders wird es nicht
funktionieren
meine Damen und Herren
es ist geboten jetzt zu handeln wir sind
im dramatischen Zeiten und Herr Minister
ein guter Krisenmanager hätte jetzt gar
keine Zeit mehr teure Haus und
hochfotografen zu engagieren oder vom
heroischen Tragen der One Love Armbinde
zu träumen dazu sind unsere Probleme
viel zu existenziell was wir jetzt
brauchen ist endlich ein Handeln für
sichere und bezahlbare Energie damit
unser Land leben kann herzlichen Dank
der Bundestag diskutiert über den Etat
des Bundeswirtschaftsministers und Ihnen
als aufmerksame Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer ist es ja vorhin schon mal
aufgefallen ich habe es auch schon mal
erklärt für alle die ein bisschen später
eingeschaltet haben ziemlich viel orange
heute in den Rhein der Abgeordneten es
ist nämlich internationaler Tag gegen
die Gewalt gegen Frauen immer am 25
November und orange
er symbolisiert die Zukunft ohne Gewalt
gegen Frauen falls ihm aufmerksam wie
sie sind aufgefallen ist wie häufig
diese Frage hier ist Farbe heute hier im
Plenum vertreten ist es spricht Bernd
Westphal der wirtschaftspolitische
Sprecher der SPD-Fraktion dieses
Bundeshaushalt es ist ist das gut
investiertes Geld das schafft die
Zukunft unseres Landes und Perspektiven
und das machen wir mit diesem
Bundeshaushalt
die Ampelkoalition stärkt
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt das
haben wir bewiesen eben mit dem
Beschluss zum Bürgergeld der gut ist das
ist ein guter Beschluss für unsere
gesellschaftliche Entwicklung wir
organisieren Unterstützung für private
Haushalte und Unternehmen der Abschlag
im Dezember ist genau das was wir jetzt
kurzfristig wirksam auf den Weg bringen
und die anderen Dinge werden doch in
dieser in diesen Sitzungswochen vor
Weihnachten auf den Weg gebracht genau
diese Komplexität dieser Sachen braucht
eben auch diese Zeit damit es gelingt
wir werden aber auch sehr positive
Impulse für Investitionen in den
Unternehmen setzen und vor allen Dingen
die Modernisierung der Infrastruktur
nach vorne bringen
gerade was den Bereich der Fachkräfte
Sicherung angeht gibt es eine
Verstärkung der aus- und Weiterbildung
gerade auch für den Bereich des
Handwerks wo dringend Fachkräfte gesucht
werden werden die
Ausbildungsmöglichkeiten finanziell
unterstützt wir werden eine Absicherung
der Forschung und Entwicklungsaufgaben
gerade mit dem mittelaufwuchs in der
Industrieforschung aber auch in den
Bereich Zimt das Programm was sehr
innovativ in den letzten Jahrzehnten
etabliert ist sind Mittel nochmal
zugeflossen gerade der Mittelstand wird
hier eine Innovationsförderung bekommen
die ihm auch stärken und auch die
Sicherung der Kaufkraft wird nicht nur
durch das Bürgergeld sondern auch mit
der Stärkung von dem Mindestlohn von
Renten von Kindergeld und anderen Dingen
und auch die Optionen die klug war 3000
€ Steuer und abgabenfrei als Instrument
zu etablieren werden die Tarifpartner
aufnehmen das schafft Kaufkraft und
stärkt unsere Wirtschaft meine Damen und
Herren
auch
zukunftsweisende Branchen wie zum
Beispiel die Gesundheitswirtschaft mit
dem ipsafe was wir haben also ein
besonderes
Investitionsvolumen für die
Gesundheitswirtschaft wird genau dieses
innovative Umfeld schaffen was wir
benötigen und auch die Luft und
Raumfahrt dort sind wir Motor der
europäischen Raumfahrt etwas was wir
wirklich mit Inhalten noch mal erfüllen
ersparen das sind Inhalte das sind
konkrete Dinge aus dem Bundeshaushalt
was sie in 5 Minuten hier geschafft
haben aber nur Kritik nicht ein
inhaltlicher Punkt aus der Union sie
machen das noch nicht so lange
vielleicht kommt ja da auch noch was
die US-Regierung will mit dem Inflation
mit will ihre Inflation mit einem
Milliarden Subventionsprogramm bekämpfen
im sogenannten Inflation reduction Act
dieses Milliardensubventionen sind
enorme Steuervorteile in den USA und sie
werden natürlich auch Einfluss haben auf
Investitionsentscheidung der Unternehmen
hier in Deutschland und deshalb brauchen
wir eine Antwort darauf Herr
Bundeswirtschaftsminister wir müssen
darüber nachdenken wie wir darauf
reagieren nächste Woche ist EU-Kommissar
Beton hier in Berlin wir haben
Gelegenheit im Wirtschaftsausschuss mit
ihm darüber zu diskutieren und ich finde
dass wir mit den Instrumenten auch
darüber nachdenken müssen mit einem zum
Beispiel etablierten industriestrompreis
die Basis für industrielle Produktion in
Deutschland zu sichern bessere
Abschreibungsmöglichkeiten und mit einer
klugen Standortpolitik dem was
entgegenzusetzen
im März hat am Mittwoch in seiner Rede
gesagt Zweifel und Bedenken hat die
Union wenn man sich den Haushalt anguckt
und die Politik der Ampel wirklich mal
ernsthaft bewertet komme ich zu ganz
anderen Ergebnissen die
Regierungskoalition modernisiert unser
Land sie spannt Schutzschirme auf zur
Überwindung der Krise sorgt für gute
investitions- und Standortbedingungen
schafft Perspektiven für alle Menschen
in unserem Land und sorgt für den
Zusammenhalt in dieser Gesellschaft das
sind alles gute Gründe zuversichtlich zu
sein herzlichen Dank und Glück auf
nächster Redner für die Fraktion DIE
LINKE Ralf lenkert
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen fast 40 Cent
kostet da eine Kilowattstunde Strom an
der Börse genau vor einem Jahr da gab es
noch kein Krieg gegen die Ukraine heute
sind es zehn Cent weniger
im juni 2019 stand Deutschland dreimal
kurz vor einem Blackout schuld war nicht
die erneuerbaren Energien Verursacher
waren jeweils Spekulanten an der Börse
die Linke lehnt Börsenspekulation ab
weil sie uns gefährdet
was vielleicht den ein oder anderen
irritiert wir sind auch für Wohlstand
für alle aber wir sind dagegen dass
einige wenige den Wohlstand für sich
beanspruchen und dadurch die Mehrheit
der Menschen verarmt
und die Börse ist ein Instrument mit dem
bei Naturkatastrophen bei kriegen oder
durch Marktmanipulation der Wohlstand
der Mehrheit zerstört wird und die
Bundesregierung sie sieht zu sie schnürt
unzureichenden entlastungspakete statt
auf die geniale Idee zu setzen
Spekulationsgewinne einzukassieren mit
einer echten übergewinnsteuerung
und mit Preiskontrollen Wucherpreise zu
beenden so schlägt es die Linke vor
und egal wie die Ampel die Bremsen nennt
es bleiben nur kosmetische Eingriffe mit
denen sie letztlich die Börse und nicht
die Menschen schützen Ihre
milliardensubvention
ihre Milliardensubventionen fließen
durch die Hände der Menschen in die
Taschen der Konzerne und dagegen und
immer wieder fordert DIE LINKE eine
Vergesellschaftung der Energiewirtschaft
und damit bleiben Energiekosten
bezahlbar damit wird
Versorgungssicherheit gewährleistet und
damit sichern wir letztlich eine
klimaneutrale Energiewirtschaft
und kurzfristig liebe Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern fordern wir bezahlbare
energiekontingente und monatliche
Direktzahlung an alle Haushalte von 75
Euro je Haushalt plus 50 Euro je Person
in jedem Monat vielen Dank
nächster Redner für die FDP-Fraktion
Hagen Reinhold
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
debatten wie die um cosco in den letzten
Wochen zeigen das endlich in der
Regierung durch die Regierung auch erst
recht durch das Wirtschaftsministerium
aber auch in der Bevölkerung in der
Wirtschaft eine wichtige Debatte
begonnen hat eine Debatte um
strategische Abhängigkeiten um
rohstoffsicherheit um die Verfügbarkeit
von Produkten aber auch um die von
strategischer Infrastruktur was ist das
eigentlich was bedeutet das für uns aber
auch darum was für Fähigkeiten ist
eigentlich in einem Land braucht um in
Zukunft erfolgreich zu sein und ich bin
froh dass wir das begonnen haben und
weiterführen werden und wir erkannt
haben dass sie Sicherung von Wohlstand
und von Arbeit auch davon abhängt welche
Fähigkeiten in diesem Land verfügbar
sind und viele Antworten darauf bietet
der Haushalt des Wirtschaftsministeriums
ich nehme mal die strategische
Abhängigkeit Energie ja wir nehmen jetzt
200 Milliarden Euro in die Hand um für
kleine mittelständische Unternehmen für
die Menschen in diesem Land Energie
bezahlbar zu machen aber er steht eben
zum Beispiel auch in diesem Haushalt
drinne eine Studie zu erarbeiten wie wir
eigentlich Tanker für LNG für
Wasserstoff in der Zukunft für unser
Land sichern können warum weil wir
erkannt haben dass Länder wie Kata nicht
nur Energie besitzen sondern sich 60
Prozent der tankerbaukapazitäten
weltweit in den nächsten Jahren schon
gesichert haben und der Preis von
Energie sich eben nicht nur
zusammensetzt aus der Verfügung
Verfügbarkeit von Energie sondern auch
den Transport und deshalb heimatfeld
kann ich gar nicht verstehen dass sie
sagen die Ampel reagiert viel zu spät
und auch noch falsch denn gucken wir uns
die Vergangenheit an da ist zu wenig
geschehen worden passiert in diesem Land
diese Fähigkeiten in Deutschland zu
erhalten ich erinnere daran wie uns die
Solarbranche abhanden gekommen ist ich
erinnere daran wie die Windkraft
gelitten hat in diesem Land wenn weitere
Fähigkeiten in dem Land abhanden kommen
dann werden wir Wohlstand und Zukunft
und Arbeit in diesem Land nicht sicher
darauf gibt dieser Bundeshaushalt
deutlicher Antworten
wir werden die Energiesicherheit in
Deutschland gewährleisten indem wir
Energie umstellen auch das braucht
Fähigkeiten unter anderem in der
maritimen Industrie wir brauchen
Errichter Schiffe vor offshore
Windkraftanlagen kabelverlegeschiffe und
so weiter und deshalb ist es wichtig
dass nicht nur die Politik die kann es
nicht alleine richten sondern auch
Wirtschaft und Bevölkerung erkannt haben
das kostet auch was und ich muss was
dafür tun die Bundesregierung die
öffentliche Hand muss erkennen dass es
wichtig ist in Europa in Deutschland
Industrie zu stärken indem ich Produkte
hier Abfrage und nicht in Asien kaufe
Gott sei Dank haben wir eine Debatte um
eine neue China Strategie die uns zeigt
wie die Abhängigkeit zu Asien ist aber
auch die Wirtschaft muss erkennen dass
es wichtig ist in Europa in Deutschland
Fähigkeiten vorzuhalten und dabei
unterstützen wir Sie bei der Maritim
Wirtschaft z.B in diesem Jahr 2003 im
nächsten Jahr 2023 62 Millionen Euro
über 50 Milliarden mehr Millionen mehr
für Verpflichtungsermächtigung 24 bis 27
um Forschung und Bildung voranzutreiben
und Fähigkeiten in Deutschland zu
erhalten die es dringend braucht
Wohlstand und Arbeit in diesem Land zu
sichern die letzten Worte will ich für
die energy Terminals aufbringen weil
auch das Lob von der CDU wahrgenommen es
einen Unterschied macht wie wir das
energy Beschleunigungsgesetz angebaut
aufgesetzt haben sie haben versucht
planungsbeschleunigung per Gesetzeskraft
bei einzelnen Vorhaben durchzusetzen wir
haben die Bürokratie abgebaut wonach die
Wirtschaft seit Jahren schreit weil wir
nämlich die Verfahren vereinfacht haben
im
umweltverträglichkeitsprüfungsverfahren
wir haben nur eine Rechtsinstanz bis zur
Sicherheit geschaffen das ist eine
Bürokratisierung die wir geschaffen
haben und nicht wie sie die letzten
Jahre der Gesetzeskraft verordnet
welches Infrastrukturprojekt entsteht
das macht den Unterschied zu dieser
Ampel wir entbürokratisieren und
schaffen Zukunft sie haben es anders
probiert das hat nicht funktioniert
deshalb ist diese fortschrittskoalition
genau die Richtige für dieses Land
der Bundestag debattiert über den
Einzelplan 09 Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz
nächster Redner Andreas junger
Parteivorsitzender cdu/csu und Klima und
energie-koalitionsvertrag zum Beispiel
bei einigen
schienenverkehrsprojekten oder aber so
wie sie es bei den lng-terminals
angegangen wurde wir freuen uns darüber
dass es so schnell gegangen ist aber ich
sage Ihnen dann auch machen sie es doch
jetzt auch bei den anderen Dingen machen
sie es bei den erneuerbaren Energien
machen sie es bei den Stromtrassen
machen sie es bei der Wasserstoff
Infrastruktur machen sie es bei der
Verkehrsinfrastruktur Deutschland muss
insgesamt schneller werden deshalb muss
dieses Verfahren mit Stil bilden werden
wenn sie das so aufgreifen unsere
Unterstützung haben wir dafür wir
fordern das Hier und Heute
und dann Herrn Kollege Junge von der SPD
wenn Sie unsere Arbeit hier als
Seitenlinie bezeichnet als Seitenlinie
sagt es wenig aus über die Union aber
viel über ihr grundlegend falsches
Verständnis von parlamentarischer
Demokratie ja ja
ihr parteivolt Franz münteferien der
sagt die Opposition ist mist ich sage
Ihnen Mist ist Biomasse aus Biomasse
kann man was Gutes machen zum Beispiel
neue Energie und in diesem Geiste gehen
wir unsere Arbeit hier an in diesem
Geiste machen wir eine konstruktive
Oppositionsarbeit und das will ich Ihnen
an ein paar Beispielen verdeutlichen
beim Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien
beim osterpaket der Minister habe weg da
haben wir nichts hier vorgeschlagen was
irgendwas gebremstätig wir haben nur
Vorschläge gemacht die will beschleunigt
hätten sie haben abgelehnt zweimal
unseren Vorschlag Steuerfreiheit für
private PV-Anlagen zweimal abgelehnt
werden drittes Mal beantragt dann haben
sie es übernommen und ist ein richtiger
Schritt und deshalb ermuntere ich sie
sie haben ist zweimal abgelegt abgelehnt
und unseren Antrag die
Registrierungspflicht für PV-Anlagen in
dieser Krise auszusetzen die muss
ausgesetzt werden der liegen überall im
Land große PV-Anlagen ich glaube die
könnten jetzt ans Netz gehen aber die
werden nicht angeschlossen weil sie
nicht bereit sind auf die Regierung
Registrierungspflicht sie verzichten
Herr Habeck ich kann mir nicht ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass sie das für
richtig halten ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass es für richtig halten
das in dieser Krise Sonnenenergie die
eingesetzt werden könnte nicht
eingesetzt wird weil sie diesen Antrag
ablehnen wir werden in den nächsten
Sitzungswoche ein drittes Mal stellen
das wäre klug wenn sie es noch mal
angucken wir werden darauf drängen wir
brauchen nicht alle Möglichkeiten der
Energieerzeugung gerade auch das was auf
unseren TV
anderen mit unserem PV-Anlagen möglich
ist dann haben Sie jetzt ein Vorschlag
vorgelegt zu auch rückwirkenden
Abschöpfung von Erträgen bei den
erneuerbaren Energien Herr Minister was
sie hier vorgelegt haben ist eine
Erneuerbaren Bremse der droht ein
Kollateralschaden für die Energiewende
es werden schon jetzt Investitionen
zurückgestellt und übrigens weil über
den Standort gesprochen wurde und hier
gesagt wurde entstand dort wurde
schlecht geredet nicht wegen
Redebeiträgen aus der Opposition sondern
wegen dieser Ankündigung aus der
Bundesregierung werden jetzt
Investitionen im TV in Windkraft
zurückgestellt die Bioenergie so neu
gedeckelt werden nehmen Sie diese Pläne
zurück der Minister die Wortwahl wird
Ihnen vielleicht nicht gefallen aber
machen Sie es wie bei der gasumlage
diese Erneuerbaren Bremse muss weg
weil es darum geht ich habe den beraten
Sie es doch mal dann beraten Sie es doch
mal das das ist doch jetzt in der Region
hier vorgeschlagen worden ich nehme wahr
Kritik aus der SPD an dem Vorschlag der
Regierung nehmen Sie es zurück das
beschädigte Energiewende müssen sie auch
beschleunigen und es muss man sich mal
genau angucken deswegen ist rückwirkend
eingegriffen werden rückwirkend
Rückwirkung ist abwirkung des
beschädigtes Vertrauen in solche
Investitionen es soll nicht etwa
tatsächliche Gewinne sondern vermutete
Erträge abgeschöpft werden es gibt jetzt
namhafte Juristen die sagen das ist
vermutlich verfassungswidrig
eu-rechtswidrig es ist aber vor allem
politisch verrückt und deshalb muss es
geändert werden wir brauchen jetzt doch
gerade eine Grundlage für den Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien die Steinkohle
wird völlig ausgenommen und die
Bioenergie soll neu gedeckelt werden die
muss da raus müssen doch jetzt in dieser
Krise alle Möglichkeiten gerade der
Bioenergie nutzen und deshalb ändern Sie
diese Pläne wir darauf wir brauchen
jetzt die Grundlage für den Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien
und der Bundeskanzler hat dazu etwas
entlaufen des gesagt in seiner Rede in
dieser Woche hat gesagt die Zukunft der
Energieversorgung das ist Wind Sonne und
grüner Wasserstoff
den zweiten Satz hätte nicht dazu gesagt
aber der spiegelt sich in ihrer Politik
wieder eben nicht Bioenergie eben nicht
Geothermie im nicht die Wasserkraft und
wir trinken darauf dass das alles in der
ganzen Breite gemacht und dass die
wasserstoffstrategie nicht verschoben
wird wie durch ihre Entscheidung der
Ampel in dieser Woche ein Jahr mit der
Bericht zur Wasserstoff Infrastruktur
verschoben statt die Dinge jetzt zu
beschleunigen zu negativen Emissionen
haben sie Einsatz im Koalitionsvertrag
aber keine einzige Initiative und mit
CCS mit ccco mit Abscheidung von
kohlendio zieht die Weichen zu stellen
dass wir Klima Neutralität mit Reduktion
der Emission und mit Abscheidung
gemeinsam erreichen bis 2045 das ist
ihre Aufgabe entsprechen sie den
Vorgaben aus dem Klimaschutzgesetz statt
es aufzuweichen legen Sie Ihre Programme
vor legen Sie die Initiativen vor wir
trinken darauf
der Wirtschaftsminister lässt sich durch
diese Rede nicht provozieren liest
weiter vor sich hin nächste Rednerin in
der Debatte ist Katrin Uhlig für Bündnis
90 die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren wir alle wissen
wie ernst die aktuelle Lage im
Energiebereich ist wir müssen neben
Maßnahmen zur Absicherung der
Versorgungssicherheit und zur
Abmilderung der Energiekrise parallel
aber auch weiterhin alles dafür tun
unsere Energieversorgung und unsere
Wirtschaft klimaneutral auszurichten
erneuerbare Energien schützen nicht nur
unser Klima sie machen uns auch
unabhängig von fossilen Importen und
sorgen für bezahlbare Energiepreise
neben dem rechtlichen Rahmen bei dem wir
mit dem osterpaket im Sommer einen
großen Schritt nach vorne gemacht haben
ist es deshalb wichtig auch mit diesem
Haushalt die richtigen Weichen zu
stellen ich freue mich deshalb sehr das
ist im parlamentarischen Verfahren
gelungen ist den Bereich Klima und
Energie nochmal zu stärken denn in
diesem Wandel liegt doch eine Chance
eine Chance für unsere Wirtschaft für
unsere Industrie für uns alle
eine Chance für mehr Wertschöpfung und
neue Märkte eine Chance für bezahlbare
Energiepreise durch erneuerbare Energien
und Energieeffizienz eine Chance uns
unabhängiger zu machen von fossilen
Importen und unser Klima zu schützen
so wird die Energiewende die Grundlage
ist für den Wandel in der Wirtschaft so
gibt es im Handwerk und bei den KMU's
die Macher der Energiewende der Kollege
Westphal hat das eben schon angesprochen
sie bauen Solaranlagen auf Dächer
installieren klimafreundliche
Heizungssysteme und treiben den Umbau
einer klimafreundlichen Produktion voran
deshalb müssen wir dringend dem
Fachkräftemangel gerade im Handwerk
entgegenwirken und stellen deshalb
zusätzliche Mittel für ein
Qualifizierungsprogramm für die
wärmewende bereit
und um den klimafreundlichen Umbau
gerade auch bei kleinen und
Kleinstbetrieben voranzutreiben sieht
der Haushaltsentwurf nun ein neues
Förderprogramm für KMU vor das gerade
kleine Betriebe dabei unterstützen soll
ihre Produktion klimafreundlich
auszurichten
neben dem schnelleren Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren und dem klimafreundlichen
Umbau unserer Wirtschaft wird allzu oft
vergessen und Herr Jung bei ihnen in der
Rede eben auch dass wir auch in
Energieeffizienz und
Energieeinsparmaßnahmen stärken müssen
deshalb ist es richtig die dass die
Bundesregierung ein energieeffizienz-
denn gerade
Energieeffizienzmaßnahmen führen zur
Energieeinsparung und zur Optimierung
von Prozessen und bieten gleichzeitig
eine Chance für innovative Ideen und
neue Märkte auch im Haushalt haben wir
deshalb diesen zentralen Punkt für die
Energiewende aufgegriffen und flankieren
die kommenden Regelungen mit Mitteln für
Energieeffizienz Beratung sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren die aktuellen
Herausforderungen sind gerade im
Energiebereich viele dieser Haushalt ist
ein wichtiger Schritt ihnen
entgegenzutreten und uns ein gutes Stück
weiter in Richtung Klimaneutralität zu
bringen wenn wir diesen Weg konsequent
fortsetzen und diese Chance ergreifen
profitieren wir Herr Kollege Mattfeld
nicht nur als Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland davon ganz herzlichen Dank
nächster Redner für die afd-fraktion
Steffen Portrait stimmt Gott Rees der
energiepolitische Sprecher der
afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren Herr Minister
Habig sie haben jetzt hier die vollen
acht Minuten dafür verwendet über
Probleme zu reden die ohne ihre Politik
nicht in diesem Maße da wären
Klima Historie Klima Historie brauchen
wir nicht denn wir haben Zeit unsere
Gesellschaft residenzfähig zu machen
gegenüber der Klimaänderung Energie
Verknappung hätten wir nicht wenn wir
Kohle verstromen würden wenn wir
Kernenergie entsprechend ans Netz
bringen würden und wenn wir russisches
Gas endlich hier zu uns bekommen würden
Energieverknappung wäre dann passiert
und die Preise würden singen ganz
einfach und die Inflation die Inflation
wäre nicht so hoch wenn Sie die EZB
auffordern würden seriöse Geldpolitik zu
machen all das machen sie nicht schade
das schade unser Land aber was sie
machen ihn ist leider den Finger ins
Ausland zeigen auf die schlimmen Dinge
in der Ukraine ja aber das hat nicht die
Probleme bei uns verursacht Herr
Minister nein
meine Damen und Herren vor 100 10 Jahren
ist die Titanic untergegangen berauscht
von der Überzeugung der Machbarkeit
ihrer Technologie wurden vielfältige
Warnungen vor Eisbergen in den Wind
geschlagen Funksprüche informierten über
Packeis und einem riesigen Eisfeld doch
Kapitän und Offiziere jeden strandkurs
und die Katastrophe nahmen ihren Lauf
und genauso ist es heute mit der
Energiewende ins Nichts jedes geradewegs
in die Insolvenz Deutschlands in den
Untergang unseres Wohlfahrtsstaates und
wie im Fall der Titanic gibt es heute
Warnungen zu auf Eon-Chef Birnbaum z.B
prognostizierte schon vor einem Jahr
dass wir in diesem Winter mit
Abschaltung ganzer Städte rechnen können
auch das Bundesamt für
Bevölkerungsschutz und Katastrophenhilfe
äußerte sich ähnlich um nur diese beiden
zu nennen und wie bei der Titanic fahren
die Verantwortlichen weiter munter volle
Kraft voraus Kurs aufs Riff
Großunternehmen
Großunternehmen setzen sich ab sehen
keine Zukunft mehr in einem Links-
von links grünen Ideologen Betonköpfen
und Politik Pfuschern regierten
Deutschland wer seine Produktion nicht
verlagern kann wie zum Beispiel der
Mittelstand erlebt eine Pleitewelle
sondern gleichen der Mittelstand der aus
eigener Kraft lebt und deshalb politisch
unabhängig ist der war globalistischen
Diktat Freund schon immer einen Dorn im
Auge der Mittelstand soll geschwächt
werden damit die Klaus schwarze
Umgestaltung unserer Gesellschaft
unserer Wirtschaft in die Planwirtschaft
weitergehen kann meine Damen und Herren
das steckt dahinter und auch sie haben
Minister Habeck sie haben den Fahrplan
doch leider in Richtung Vergangenheit
sie wollen sich um
coole Sachen kümmern wie sie sagen und
wofür wollen Sie denn diese Steuergelder
ausgeben für Batteriezellen für
Elektrolyse für Sonnen- und Windstrom
also alles Techniken aus dem letzten
oder vorletzten Jahrhundert alles
Techniken die lebenslang nicht ohne
Subventionen auskommen können meine
Damen und Herren kaum ein Wort zu
zukunftsweisender Industrie und Dinge
die Zukunft schaffen meine Damen und
Herren diese Bundesregierung hat fertig
[Applaus]
die Feststellung von Stefan kotré von
der AFD der Bundestag debattiert über
den Einzelplan 009 Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz
14,57 Milliarden hat Robert Habeck zur
Verfügung das sind 3,1% des
Gesamthaushaltes immerhin Andreas
auf den Eisberg zu fahren das sind sie
beim Thema Klimaschutz
Olaf Scholz hat bei der
Weltklimakonferenz in Sharm el-Sheikh
sehr deutlich eingefordert wir brauchen
mehr Tempo und mehr Ehrgeiz beim Umstieg
auf erneuerbare Energie mit diesem
Vorsatz sind wir als Ampel angetreten
und diesen Vorsatz setzen wir um das
zeigt nicht zuletzt der Haushalt den wir
heute beschließen werden
meine Damen und Herren natürlich bildet
der Haushalt die aktuelle
Krisensituation ab und ermöglicht uns
dass wir entschlossen gegen die hohen
Energiepreise Vorgehen wir haben letzte
Sitzungswoche die dezemberhilfe
beschlossen die Sie Herr sparen vorher
leider vergessen haben heute beschließt
das Kabinett den Gesetzentwurf für die
Gas und strompreisbremse
aber neben diesen kurzfristigen
notwendigen Maßnahmen schaffen wir es
natürlich trotzdem unseren Fokus auf
Klimaschutz und Energie zu legen
zusätzlich zu all den
Entlastungsmaßnahmen müssen wir
gleichzeitig genauso dringend auch die
Weichen für unsere Energieversorgung der
Zukunft stellen wir müssen schnell weg
von Kohle Öl und Gas wir brauchen eine
nachhaltige und sozialgerechte
Energiewende und wir müssen die
Industrie erfolgreich dekarbonisieren
nur wenn wir der Welt zeigen dass dieser
Weg gut funktioniert haben wir noch eine
Chance die Erderwärmung auf 1,5 Grad zu
begrenzen
meine Damen und Herren viele der
notwendigen Maßnahmen brauchen aber
entsprechende finanzielle
Rahmenbedingungen damit sie auch
umgesetzt werden diese Rahmenbedingungen
schaffen wir mit dem Haushalt den wir
heute beschließen die Ausgaben die wir
dort vorsehen für den Klimaschutz sind
gut angelegt das Geld weil wir es in
eine klimaneutrale Zukunft investieren
Investitionen in CO2-freien Strom sind
ein zentraler Baustein die
Karbonisierung bedeutet aber auch
Investitionen in eine andere Mobilität
in energieeffiziente Gebäude und den
Grünen Produktionsprozesse 35 Milliarden
Euro werden wir nächstes Jahr dafür aus
dem Klima und transformationsfond
bereitstellen wir gehen damit alle
wichtigen Bereiche an in denen wir
schnell Emissionen einspannen müssen 16
Milliarden Euro sind für mehr Effizienz
und mehr erneuerbare im Gebäudebereich
vorgesehen 4 Milliarden geben wir für
Elektroautos und zusätzliche Ladesäulen
aus mit 2,2 Milliarden Euro unterstützen
wir klimaneutrale Industrieprozesse und
mit Milliarden Euro den Einsatz von
grünem Wasserstoff aber auch viele
kleine Projekte die wir im
klima-wende voranzutreiben das neue
Aufbauprogramm Wärmepumpen mit 15
Millionen zum Beispiel
der
klima-schutzes im Mittelpunkt aber auch
im eigenen Haushalt des
klimaschutzministeriums setzen wir
wichtige Schwerpunkte wir stellen fast
700 Millionen Euro für die
Energieforschung und die real Labore der
Energiewende zur Verfügung für den
Klimaschutz und den Schutz der
Biodiversität im Ausland sind es 710
Millionen und für den internationalen
Aufbau der Wasserstoffwirtschaft können
wir die nächsten vier Jahre können wir
die nächsten Jahre fast vier Milliarden
Euro Festplatten und wenn Sie lieber
Herr Jung den Irrsinn fordern Mittel für
den internationalen Klimaschutz zu
streichen brauchen Sie sich über
schlechte Bewertungen ihre
Oppositionsarbeit leider nicht wundern
meine Damen und Herren mit dem Haushalt
und der Mauern wir unseren Weg zum
klimaneutralen Wirtschaften zur
klimaneutralen Mobilität und zum
klimaneutralen heizen Klimaschutz
versorgen Sicherheit und Entlastungen
das bringen wir mit diesem Haushalt
alles zusammen
nächster Redner für die FDP-Fraktion
Olaf in der Weg
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren nach intensiven
Beratung schließen wir nun den
Einzelplan 09 für das Bundesministerium
für Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz es liegt
ein Haushalt vor der einerseits die
Schlagkraft unseres
Wirtschaftsstandortes und Mittelstandes
erhält und andererseits wichtige Impulse
beim Klimaschutz und bei Innovation
setzt im Haushalt liegt ein besonderer
Fokus auf der Sicherung der
Energieversorgung hier wird gezielt
investiert um die Energiesicherheit in
Deutschland in diesen und in den
kommenden Wintern zu gewährleisten
die neuen die neuen lng-terminals die in
Rekordzeit errichtet werden und ich
finde 194 Tage im Wilhelmshaven wirklich
beeindruckend
ja da dürfen glaube ich auch mal
klatschen
das ist aber nur ein Beispiel wie wir
die Bundesmittel gezielt und
unbürokratisch einsetzen und investieren
und obwohl wir die Energieversorgung
sicherstellen werden wir nicht alle
gestiegenen Belastungen als Staat
abfedern können neben den Bürgern und
dem Mittelstand werden wir vor allem die
energieintensive Industrie aber spürbar
entlasten können das ist gut wir stellen
sicher dass der Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland erhalten bleibt und
weiterhin gestärkt wird wir sorgen
weiterhin dafür dass durch Umschichtung
bei Investitionsprogramm deutlich
stärkere Ansätze für mehr Klimaschutz in
der Industrie gesetzt werden denn
vielmehr
denn viel mehr als staatliche Vorgaben
brauchen wir die Innovationskraft der
deutschen Industrie für echten wirksamen
Klimaschutz unsere Aufgabe
unsere Aufgabe als Deutscher Bundestag
gemeinsam mit der Bundesregierung ist es
hier für optimale Rahmenbedingungen zu
sorgen und diese Innovationskraft
brauchen wir auch für den
internationalen Klimaschutz denn andere
Staaten können genauso von neuen
Technologien profitieren hier müssen wir
auch den Handel deutlich vorantreiben
mit der internationalen
Klimaschutzinitiative unterstützen wir
zudem auch Entwicklungsländer bei
Maßnahmen zur Biodiversität denn das ist
unsere Verantwortung wobei natürlich
immer die Überprüfung der Maßnahmen
erforderlich ist und bleibt ein weiterer
wichtiger Baustein ist die
wasserstoffstrategie die ebenfalls in
diesem Haushalt verankert ist wir nutzen
auch hier die Chancen der Globalisierung
und stellen uns auf den schnellen
Hochlauf vom Wasserstoff ein denn dabei
dürfen wir unter keinen Umständen den
Anschluss verlieren hier müssen wir wie
gerade schon angesprochen mit der EU
zügig Antworten auf den Vorstoß aus den
USA finden
und zu guter Letzt liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen um die Energiewende umzusetzen
brauchen wir vor allem aber Menschen
Menschen die anpacken wir brauchen wir
haben bereits jetzt einen massiven
Fachkräftemangel und deshalb ist es gut
dass wir auch die berufliche Bildung im
Handwerk mit diesem Haushalt stärken die
Handwerkerinnen und Handwerker sind die
Klimaschützer unsere Zeit sie sie
verdienen nicht nur unsere Wertschätzung
und Unterstützung sondern wir werden
dafür sorgen dass es zukünftig noch viel
mehr von ihnen gibt diese Haushalt ist
geprägt von Weitsicht und Fortschritt
und genau das brauchen wir nicht nur in
diesen Herausforderungen Zeiten vielen
Dank
Olaf in der Weg war das für die FDP der
nächste Redner hier
am letzten Tag der Haushaltsdebatte zum
Einzelplan 09 Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz
ist Hans-jürgen durchs für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren bei den
Haushaltsberatungen im März hat
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck kritisiert in
Deutschland würden sich die Menschen nur
noch bewegen wenn Sie einen finanziellen
Klopps auf den Hintern bekämen so sehr
würde die Wirtschaft über subventioniert
dieser Haushalt hat ein noch höheres
Niveau doch was dem Haushalt fehlt ist
eine klare Prioritätensetzung Richtung
Zukunft
als Union haben wir Ihnen den Haushalt
in den Haushaltsberatungen ein Angebot
zur Prioritätensetzung unterbreitet denn
wir haben Ihnen Vorschläge für ein
Wachstumspaket vorgestellt dass die
Angebotsseite in den Blick nimmt denn
wir wissen doch in Deutschland werden
die Energiepreise nicht mehr auf das
Niveau von vor der ukraine-krise
zurückfallen und deswegen müssen wir in
anderen Bereichen umso besser werden um
die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit international
auch wieder herzustellen und zu
erreichen
neue Ideen
neue Ideen und Reformbereitschaft
spiegelt dieser Haushalt aber viel zu
wenig wieder
wer mit den Unternehmern in unserem Land
spricht der hört vor allem drei Themen
mit denen sie sich tagtäglich intensiv
auseinandersetzen die sie umtreiben
sitzt zuallererstes Thema Inflation und
Energiepreise zum zweiten ist das Thema
nach wie vor Lieferketten und zum
dritten der Mangel an Fachkräften
mittlerweile im Grunde in allen Branchen
während die Ampel die Wirtschaft bei den
ersten entlastungspaketen komplett
vergessen hat haben wir als Union
konkrete Vorschläge dazu vorgelegt
und Priorität Nummer eins muss sein die
Belastungen der Wirtschaft müssen
gesenkt werden seit Monaten fordern wir
ein belastungsmoratorium eine Zeit lang
haben wir das auch von der FDP gehört
bisher allerdings Fehlanzeige helfen
würde auch die Beschleunigung von
Planungs- und Genehmigungsverfahren ist
mehrfach in der Debatte angesprochen
worden in Zusammenhang mit lng-terminals
hat das sehr gut funktioniert aber wir
brauchen es eben auch in sämtlichen
anderen Bereichen und die drastische
Reduzierung der Bürokratie davon hören
wir uns sehen wir im regierungshandel
sehr sehr wenig und schon heute ist klar
dass wir zum Ende des Jahres das Ziel
nämlich sämtliche
Verwaltungsdienstleistungen knapp 600 zu
digitalisieren in Deutschland meilenweit
verfehlen werden die Unternehmen in
unserem Land gerade die kleinen und
mittelständischen die brauchen dringend
Entlastungen
und dann müssen wir die Weichen auf
Zukunft stellen und das passiert zu
wenig in diesem Haushalt wir müssen bei
der nächsten welletechnologischer
Innovationen unbedingt mit dabei sein
oder ist es sehr bemerkenswert dass der
Minister als Beispiel für
Zukunftsfähigkeit in diesem Haushalt
ausgerechnet die Cloud-Technologien und
die digitalen Technologien anspricht in
beiden Bereichen wurde der
Haushaltsentwurf gegenüber dem Vorjahr
deutlich gekürzt in einem Fall sogar um
50% gekürzt bei den
Cloud-Infrastrukturen
und dann ja das sind genau die Zahlen
des Haushalts und dann haben wir Anträge
dazu gestellt genau zu diesen Themen und
im Anschluss wurde im einen Fall
zumindest ein klein wenig und im anderen
Fall deutlich die Haushaltspositionen
aufgestockt das spricht eindeutig dafür
sie sollten sehr viel öfter die Anträge
der Union nicht nur lesen sondern ihnen
auch zustimmen dann sind Sie auf dem
richtigen Weg
natürlich geht es aktuell vor allem
darum die Wirtschaft am Laufen zu halten
es muss aber auch darum gehen die
Weichen in Richtung Zukunft zu stellen
und das schafft dieser Haushalt nicht
vielen Dank
hat noch einmal angesprochen das vor
allen Dingen für den Mittelstand was
getan werden muss die Union hat auch
einen Änderungsantrag dazu und fordert
unter anderem beruflichen Bildung für
den Mittelstand lehrlingsunterweisung
dort einen zusätzlichen Titel von 75
Millionen Euro aufzusetzen Lena Werner
jetzt für die SPD
hat die Regierung es geschafft ein
Haushalt aufzustellen der zeigt dass wir
nicht nur kurzfristige Krisenbewältigung
beherrschen sondern auch langfristig
zukunftsfähige Voraussetzungen für
unsere Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft
schaffen und genau da unterscheidet sich
nämlich auch die Wahrnehmung und darauf
werde ich jetzt darauf eingehen wo wir
zukunftsorientiert investieren werden
wir können nämlich auch Fehler
korrigieren denn vor ein paar Monaten
habe ich genau hier über die Wichtigkeit
der europäischen Projekte gesprochen und
betont dass wir uns weiter am wichtigen
Zukunftsprojekt
itci health beteiligen müssen und genau
das ist uns jetzt in diesem Haushalt
gelungen damit können wir an die bereits
bestehenden erfolgreichen Projekte
anknüpfen und gemeinsam in Europa
wichtige neue Impulse in der gehen und
Zellforschung vorantreiben
ein weiteres wichtiges Zukunftsthema für
das ich mich als Berichterstatterin
stark einsetze ich ist der Bereich Games
überraschend wurde bekanntgegeben dass
der Topf für alle für die Förderung
ausgeschöpft war und das zeigt wie gut
das Programm angenommen wird und dass
der Bedarf in Deutschland da ist aber
gleichzeitig ist klar dass die Förderung
weiterlaufen muss um in dieser
wachsenden und umkämpften Branche auf
dem europäischen aber auch international
international Markt wettbewerbsfähig zu
bleiben da freue ich mich sehr dass es
kurzfristig gelungen ist hier die Mittel
noch einmal kräftig zu erhöhen das ist
ein starkes Signal an eine innovative
und enorme zukunftsfähige Branche die
Wertschöpfung betreibt und Fachkräfte
mobilisiert
vielen Dank daher an die Kollegin annaka
sautsky und den Kollegen Frank junge für
die gemeinsame Arbeit und die
Unterstützung von diesem wichtigen
Projekt
auch im Tourismus konnten wir noch mal
weitere wichtige Mittel organisieren vor
der Bereinigungssitzung des
Haushaltsausschusses hatten wir bereits
einen mittelaufwuchs von 4,6 Millionen
Euro für die deutsche Zentrale für
Tourismus erwürgen können und es freut
mich ganz besonders dass jetzt noch
weitere 1,5 Millionen Euro dazukommen
damit steigt das Budget der DZT auf 40,6
Millionen Euro für das Jahr 2023 und
damit können wir die Potenziale des
stark gebeutelten deutschen Tourismus
weiter stärken
auf der ganzen Welt vermarktete DCT die
Vielfalt des Tourismusland Deutschland
und zu dieser Vielfalt zählt
insbesondere ein nachhaltiger Tourismus
denn unsere Hotels Gastronomie in
Freizeitparks die
Veranstaltungswirtschaft und viele
weitere Unternehmen investieren viel
Herzblut und finanzielle Mittel in einen
nachhaltigen und umweltverträglichen
Tourismus diese Anstrengung erstrecken
sich über viele Bereiche die
Identifizierung von CO2 Einsparpotenzial
die Stärkung des ländlichen Raums und
der damit verbundenen Erschließung neuer
touristischer Potenziale und dem Ausbau
der Kreislaufwirtschaft die DZT trägt
dafür Sorge dass auch international eine
entsprechende Sichtbarkeit für den
nachhaltigen Tourismusstandort
Deutschland geschaffen wird
Nachhaltigkeit
Umweltbewusstsein und klimaneutrales
reisen sollen mit einer Reise nach
Deutschland in Verbindung gebracht
werden das soll zu unserem Markenkern
werden und unseren Tourismus
zukunftsfähig machen hier kann die
Tourismusbranche als Impulsgeber und
Katalysator für weitere wirtschaftliche
Branchen in Deutschland dienen und zum
Abschluss meiner Rede würde ich gerne
noch kurz auf das a-teile eingehen weil
in dieser Woche öfters negativ darüber
gesprochen wurde man kann in das A3
reisen die Menschen dort freuen sich
sehr auf sie und sie heißen sie auch
sehr gerne willkommen und deswegen
meiner pay fahren Sie gerne hin und
machen sie dort Urlaub vielen Dank
der nächste Redner in der Debatte
Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz Einzelplan 09
ist Robert farle er ist einer von sechs
fraktionslosen Abgeordneten im September
ist er aus der Partei und der Fraktion
der AFD ausgetreten einer von fünf
Austritten schon in dieser
Legislaturperiode bei der AFD
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren der Kern der
deutschen Industrie und der Mittelstand
wird von der ampelregierung im Zuge der
großen Transformation
planmäßig ruiniert
das geschieht auch ganz bewusst mir geht
es darum dass dahinterstehende
Geschäftsmodell der künstlich
herbeigeredeten Klimakrise aufzuzeigen
denn Klimaschutz ist bei Ihnen nur der
denkmantel für ihre wirklichen Ziele
erstens Milliardäre und us-hedgefonds
Manager finanzieren Wissenschaftler für
Auftragsarbeiten die das Märchen vom
menschengemachten klimaan Wandel überall
hin transportieren sollen zweitens
dieselben Investoren finanzieren
lobby-organisationen wie die Agora
Energiewende die diese fake-studien als
Grundlage für ihre politischen
Forderungen Nutzen in diesem Fall die
Energiewende diese wiederum dieselben
Investoren in den USA finanzieren
sogenannte klimaaktivisten wie Fridays
for future instinction Rebellion oder
die letzte Generation um ihren
Forderungen Nachdruck zu verleihen und
das Thema in den Medien dauerpräsent zu
halten das Ziel ist dann erreicht wenn
dadurch staatliche
milliardenschwere Investitionsprogramme
ausgelöst werden die für die Profite
derselben Investoren sorgen und das ist
ihre Aufgabe Herr Habeck wie weit der
Einfluss dieser Investoren auf die
Bundesregierung bereits vorangeschritten
ist zeigt sich an den
personalbesetzungen der grün geführten
Ministerien Annalena perbock hat die
US-amerikanische ex-chefin von
Greenpeace international Jennifer Morgan
zur Staatssekretärin im Auswärtigen Amt
gemacht Robert Habeck hat fast die
komplette spitzenriege seines
Ministeriums gegen Energiewende
Lobbyisten ausgetauscht den ehemaligen
Direktor der Lobby-Organisation agora
Energie-
und soll künftig chefökonomin bei
havixministerium werden dazu zitiere ich
aus der Märzausgabe des manager-magazins
Zitat die Protagonisten der
ökoprotestbewegung halten nun die Macht
in der Hand die Rebellen sind jetzt
Regenten er der grüne Staatssekretär
Sven gigolf will die soziale
Marktwirtschaft Ludwig Erhardt in die
ökologisch soziale Marktwirtschaft
Robert habecks umbauen der Umbau der
Volkswirtschaft wird Verlierer haben
Gewinner und super Gewinner
großbritäre
großprofiteure der Staatsmilliarden
Zitat Ende die Grünen Minister sind
somit die Handlanger der großprofiteure
der Energiewende die sich den Staat als
der bedienungs-
sichern während umgekehrt die
traditionellen Industrien die
Automobilindustrie die Chemieindustrie
und andere Industrien praktisch
gezwungen werden dieses Land zu
verlassen weil die Energiepreise für sie
nicht mehr bezahlbar sind und das kostet
hunderttausende Arbeitsplätze sie haben
es sind an dieses
realisierungsminister der die
Exportnation Deutschland auslöschen soll
vielen Dank
Robert fahl und schön eingefangen von
unserer Regie der zuständige Minister
der ja hier auch mehrfach Adressat war
der Rede von Robert fahle fraktionsloser
Abgeordneter im Deutschen Bundestag
nächster Redner in der Debatte Timon
gremmels für die SPD-Fraktion
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren Herr Fahne für diese
guten Verschwörungstheorien hätten sie
gar nicht aus der afd-fraktion austreten
müssen das passt da ganz hervorragend zu
wer muss man muss man an dieser Stelle
dazu nicht sagen ja wir beraten heute
den Einzelplan 09 dass Budget des
Ministeriums für wirtschafte Klimaschutz
ich finde diese beiden Themen Wirtschaft
und Klimaschutz Energiewende das gehört
zusammen wie
wir sind eingefallen parlamentarisch das
passt hervorragend weil genauso geht
Energiewende wir wollen natürlich unser
Wirtschaftssystem umbauen wir wollen es
nachhaltig machen wir wollen es
resilient machen wir wollen es
zukunftsgerichtet ausbauen das ist die
Aufgabe die unsere Generation jetzt hier
hat ein weiter so wird sozusagen das in
den einzelnen Abgrund führen und das
wäre verantwortungslose Politik wenn wir
hier auf die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der CDU und anderen hören meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren und deswegen
haben wir richtige Weichen gestellt der
Fokus war jetzt immer auf ng-ports auf
Gas Einspeicherung auf Verträge auf
Atomkraft wir haben viel zu wenig
darüber hier geredet was diese Regierung
gemacht hat um die erneuerbaren Energien
voranzubringen das EEG 2023 ist das
modernste und fortschrittlichste gesetzt
was dazu führt dass wir den Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien schnell
voranbringen zügig voranbringen wir
werden in Zukunft von Windkraft von
photovoltai von Biomasse stärken und
ausbauen
Wärmepumpen auch was mir und uns jetzt
aber wichtig ist dass wir möglichst viel
der industriellen Wertschöpfung für
diese Bereiche in Deutschland halten und
auch wieder ansiedeln das ist nämlich
moderne Industriepolitik und deswegen
brauchen wir eine europäische
abgestimmte Antwort auf beides Inflation
reduction Act das ist notwendig weil
wenn wir jetzt nicht schnell solche
Antworten geben werden Unternehmen
abwandern weil die Dinge die da aus den
USA kommen so spannend und interessant
sind und ich fand das ja ganz
interessant als Herr Merz in seiner Rede
hier zum Generaldebatte auch auf den
Inflation Redaktion Act eingegangen ist
das als vorbildlich bezeichnet hat
spannend nur ist das sozusagen die Union
gegen die Klima und Transformation klagt
das passt doch alles nicht zusammen weil
da stecken genau auch ein Teil der Mitte
drin die wir für den Umbau der
Industriegesellschaft dringend brauchen
das was sie machen ist in unkonsequent
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
von der Union ja und deswegen müssen wir
jetzt aufpassen dass wir bei dem
Gesetzesentwurf der ja heute im Kabinett
und dann in den nächsten Wochen im
Bundestag den nächsten beiden Wochen
beraten verabschiedet wird zur Gas und
strompreisbremse der richtig und wichtig
ist aber wir müssen hier die richtigen
Signale aussenden wir dürfen es nicht
zulassen dass wir Signale aussenden dass
die Unternehmen und die Branchen die wir
brauchen um die Energiewende
hinzukriegen die erneuerbaren Energien
dass die Signale bekommen dass sozusagen
hier übermäßig Gewinne abgeschöpft
werden und deswegen müssen wir
klugerweise und richtigerweise darüber
nachdenken ob es nicht Mittel und Wege
gibt wie eine reinvestitionsquote zu
verankern darüber sollten wir noch mal
in den nächsten zwei Wochen wirklich
unsere Köpfe zusammenstecken weil sonst
ist es das falsche Signal was wir senden
oder wir müssen auch darüber nachdenken
ob wir nicht die Vergütungssätze im
Bereich Photovoltaik den sogenannten
Deckel auch wieder anheben weil gerade
die Kosten zeigen und es wäre doch
wirklich nicht vermittelbar nach außen
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
ich glaube dass das
Wirtschaftsministerium und Robert
Habegger auf einen guten Weg ist der
Roundtable den sie am Montag zum Ausbau
der Produktionskapazitäten für die
Energiewende auf die Weg gebracht haben
und wo sie die ersten Ergebnisse
verkündet haben ist vielversprechend wir
müssen da vielleicht noch ein Stück
schneller werden ich weiß ihr
Ministerium arbeitet an der
Kapazitätsgrenze aber wir müssen jetzt
schnell Antworten darauf finden damit
wir möglichst viel der Wertschöpfung der
Erneuerbaren Industrie in Deutschland in
Europa halten in diesem Sinne glück auf
Timon gremmels für die SPD und die
nächste Rednerin die kennen Sie
sicherlich noch meine Damen und Herren
Anja Karliczek ja die gibt es auch noch
von der cdu/csu immer ein
Bundesbildungsministerin und sie ist in
dieser Legislaturperiode die
tourismuspolitische Sprecherin der
Unionsfraktion
die
branchenden Menschen schon mal einmal
erwähnt hat nämlich die Tourismusbranche
und ich bin in diesen Tagen sehr viel
unterwegs in Hotelerie und Gastronomie
über Reisebüro ist bei
Reisebusunternehmen bei
Tourismusverbänden vor Ort und ich höre
überall und deswegen sind diese 0,4 %
plus bei der Wirtschaftsleistung auch
diese Stande gekommen der Sommer war gut
aber die Aussicht auf den Winter
bereitet große Sorgen die finanzielle
Lage nach den corona-schließungen ist
vielfach be eigentlich die Umsätze sind
bei vielen immer noch geringer als im
Vergleichsjahr 2019 die Einkaufspreise
explodieren übrigens nicht nur bei Gas
und Strom Fachkräfte werden in
händeringend gesucht am Flughafen
genauso wie im Gastgewerbe und deswegen
ist eine gute Wintersaison für die
Tourismusbranche von existenzieller
Bedeutung und deshalb ist es maximal
kontraproduktiv wenn der amtierende
Gesundheitsminister immer wieder
corona-alarm schlägt denn unwegbarkeit
schädigt das Geschäft dann fahren die
Menschen woanders hin und das können wir
glaube ich alle miteinander nicht wollen
und weil diese Branche wieder mitten im
Sturm steht wäre es gut wenn diese
Regierung und diese tragenden Fraktionen
endlich begreifen das Planungssicherheit
in volatilen Zeiten ein Wert an sich ist
wir werden uns auf steigende
Volatilitäten einstellen müssen und mehr
Volatilität bedeutet unternehmer müssen
flexibler reagieren können und deswegen
sind mehr Vorschriften mehr Regeln in
diesen Tagen mehr Gift denn je lassen
Sie unternehmen etwas unternehmen und
dann werden sie mit Unwägbarkeiten
dieser Tage schon fertig die Branche mit
ihren mehr als 3 Millionen Beschäftigten
erwartet übrigens auch dass sie Ihnen
baldmöglichst mal etwas sagen zu der
Entfristung des ermäßigten
Mehrwertsteuersatzes auch das ist
Planungssicherheit in diesen Tagen der
Bundeskanzler der Finanzminister haben
das mehrfach versprochen und bisher
gebrochen und damit erhielten zum
Beispiel die Unternehmerinnen und
Unternehmer die genau in diesen Tagen
mit jedem zu kämpfen müssen die
Planungssicherheit die Sie brauchen um
mehr Mitarbeiter anzuwerben und auch
weitere Investitionen gerade in das
Thema Nachhaltigkeit tätigen zu können
einen weiteren Punkt will ich Ihnen noch
mit auf den Weg geben Frau hehdorfer die
Chefin der deutschen Zentrale für
Tourismus hat in einer der letzten
Anhörungen sehr gut beschrieben worum es
aktuell im Tourismus geht sie sagte in
Krisenzeiten werden Marktanteile neu
verteilt der Kampf um neue
zahlungskräftige Gäste ist weltweit und
europaweit in aller Heftigkeit entbrannt
rund um Deutschland investieren viele
Regierungen massiv in den Ausbau ihrer
Werbung für den heimischen Tourismus und
mit knapp sechs Millionen Euro Frau
werner hat angesprochen im nächsten Jahr
für die DZT wird Deutschland in diesem
Wettbewerb nicht die Nase vorn haben sie
haben damit den Haushalt mit dem
Haushalt 23 immer noch nicht das Niveau
von 2021 erreicht sie müssen klotzen und
kleckern nicht und kleckern nicht in
dieser Situation
und
Deutschland ist ein hoch angesehenes
Reiseland kulturell in der mit der Natur
kulinarisch aber was hilft das wenn das
am Ende viel zu wenige wissen wir
brauchen gerade jetzt gerade jetzt wo
alles teurer wird die gut zahlende
Kundschaft aus aller Welt und wenn sie
nur dort werben von wo man mit Bus und
Bahn nach Deutschland kommen kann dann
werden wir genau diesen Zug verpassen
und dann kommen wir immer wieder das
Zitat der Chefin in den Sinn in der
Krise werden die Marktanteile neu
verteilt nur leider Deutschland wird
nicht der Profiteur davon sein zum
Leidwesen der vielen vielen Menschen dem
Tourismus arbeiten
die tourismuspolitische Sprecherin der
Unionsfraktion und der letzte Redner
hier zum Einzelplan 09 Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz kommt von der SPD Hannes
Walter erstell vertretender Vorsitzender
des Wirtschaftsausschusses
lieber Kollegen von neun Monaten begann
der völkerrechtswidrige Angriff
Russlands auf die Ukraine seither sehen
wir bei einer täglich Russland lässt
nichts unversucht ein Teil in unsere
Gesellschaft zu treiben ob gaserpressung
das Verbreiten von Fake News oder
Cyberangriffe auf Unternehmen die Liste
lässt sich beliebig fortsetzen sicher
ist aber unsere Gesellschaft ist stark
unsere Wirtschaft des resilient wir
setzen uns mit der geballten Kraft
unseres Landes für unsere gemeinsamen
Werte und unsere Freiheit ein
dem Einzelplan 09 kommt hierbei eine
Schlüsselrolle zu das sehen wir
beispielhaft am zukunftspaket zur
Transformation der ravaneriestandorte
Schwedt und Leuna damit sorgen wir dafür
dass Deutschland unabhängiger vom
russischen Öl wird deshalb investieren
wir in den nächsten zehn Jahren 375
Millionen Euro an Bundesmitteln in die
Sicherung und die erfolgreiche
Transformation der ostdeutschen
raffineriestandort und Häfen
darüber hinaus stellt der Bund 400
Millionen Euro zur Ertüchtigung der
Pipeline Rostock spät zur Verfügung
damit machen wir klar wir lassen uns
nicht erpressen wir machen uns
unabhängig und wir investieren
gleichzeitig in die Zukunft aus
Deutschlands
wir sorgen dafür dass Arbeitsplätze
erhalten und neue geschaffen werden
damit geben wir den Menschen Sicherheit
Sicherheit in herausfordernden Zeiten
das Beispiel Schwedt zeigt die Krise zu
managen und unser Land dabei
zukunftsfest zu machen sind zwei Seiten
einer Medaille heute legen wir den
Grundstein für den Wohlstand von morgen
und hier setzt die Ampel die richtigen
Akzente wir investieren in die
Innovationskraft unserer Wirtschaft um
im internationalen Wettbewerb mithalten
zu können brauchen wir innovative
Unternehmen den zentralen
Innovationsprogramm Mittelstand kurz
Zimt was schon mehrfach zu Recht
Erwähnung gefunden hat hier heute haben
wir ein wichtiges Förderinstrument und
kleine und mittelständische Unternehmen
zu unterstützen
[Applaus]
gerade weil es schon so oft hier erwähnt
wurde heute bin ich auch sicher dass
ganz viele von ihnen auch Unternehmen in
ihrem Wahlkreis haben die von dem Zinn
profitieren können bei mir zum Beispiel
ist es die schönborner Armaturen GmbH
mit dem engagierten Geschäftsführer
Stich regelmäßig im Austausch und genau
solche Beispiele zeigen dieses
Unternehmen
ist erfolgreich und das gibt dem
Programm recht
ich bin daher froh dass wir nach
zwischenzeitlichen Problemen wieder mit
voller Fahrt unterwegs sind die
deutlicher Erhöhung des gesamttitels auf
700 Millionen Euro für das nächste
Haushaltsjahr ist ein wichtiges Signal
an unseren Mittelstand
wichtig ist auch dass wir die gute
Qualität der dualen Ausbildung weiter
investieren nicht dass seit diesem Jahr
suchen Unternehmen in allen Regionen und
Branchen händeringend nach Fachkräften
gerade das Handwerk steht vor großen
Herausforderungen dabei brauchen wir
hier in Zukunft noch mehr gut
qualifizierter Fachkräfte ohne sie
werden wir den Strukturwandel und auch
die Energiewende nicht schaffen es geht
darum Solaranlagen auf Dächer zu
installieren Heizungsanlagen in
Wohnhäusern zu modernisieren und Gebäude
effizienter zu machen als
handwerksbeauftragter der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion geht natürlich
mein großer Dank auch an Frank junge
Frank Junge hat immer ein wachen Blick
für das Handwerk und setzt sich dafür in
dem Haushaltsausschuss auch immer ganz
hervorragend ein vielen Dank
deswegen die Kürzung des Titels über
betriebliche lehrlingsunterweisung wie
ursprünglich im Haushalt vorgesehen
passt einfach nicht in unsere Zeit es
ist richtig und wichtig dass dieser
Fehler im parlamentarischen Verfahren
korrigiert wurde mit nun 70 Millionen
Euro sind wir ein wichtiges Signal an
das Handwerken wir meinen es ernst wir
werden die duale Ausbildung stärken und
wir sorgen weiterhin für eine gute
Qualität der Ausbildung
sie sehen wir haben einen guten
Haushaltsentwurf und parlamentarischen
Verfahren noch besser gemacht jetzt
haben wir einen Haushalt der Sicherheit
in schwierigen Zeiten gibt und
gleichzeitig Investitionen in unsere
Zukunft ermöglicht vielen Dank und
Glückauf
ich schließe die Aussprache wir kommen
zur Abstimmung über den Einzelplan 09
Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz in der ausschussfassung
hierzu liegen ein Änderungsantrag der
Fraktion der cdu/csu sowie eine
Änderungsantrag der Fraktion der AFD vor
wir kommen zum Änderungsantrag der
Fraktion der cdu/csu auf Drucksache
4554 wer stimmt dafür
ja die cdu/csu fordert mehr Geld für die
berufliche Bildung und für den
Mittelstand sowie für Fachkräfte
Sicherungen im September hatten wir ein
Fachkräftemangel von 873.000 Menschen in
Deutschland
gut der Änderungsantrag ist gegen die
Stimmen der CDU CSU-Fraktion und der
Fraktion Die Linke
mit den Stimmen der Koalitionsfraktionen
und der afd-fraktion abgelehnt
Änderungsantrag der Fraktion der AFD auf
Drucksache
4.55 wer stimmt dafür
die AFD wiederum will die Streichung ein
einzelner Titel unter anderem die Kraft
Fachkräfte Sicherung pardon für kleine
und mittlere Unternehmen weil hierdurch
aktiv Menschen aus fremden Kulturkreisen
zusätzlich zu bereits vorhandenen
Migration zu Einwanderung nach
Deutschland ermuntert würden
dann kommen wir zur Abstimmung über den
Einzelplan wurde abgelehnt dafür
danke wer stimmt dagegen das ist jetzt
hier auf junge den Einzelplan 09
14,57 Milliarden Euro hat Robert Habeck
im kommenden Jahr zur Verfügung
angenommen